the names and the stories in this
episode have been omitted to protect the
privacy of the individuals involved
this is Jocko podcast number 77 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willing good
evening echo good evening and tonight we
welcome back to the show
retired Chief Warrant Officer Rodger
Hayden and if you don't know who Rodger
Hayden is then just stop right now and
go back to episode 37 of this podcast
and you can listen to Roger came on for
a short period time we had some time
constraints on the first time that Roger
came on but he's one of the men on which
the reputation of the SEAL Teams is
built started off as a frogman member of
the underwater demolition teams and
deployed to Vietnam with underwater
demolition team 12 and then came back
and checked into SEAL team one where he
deployed again two times to Vietnam and
then spent 30 years in the SEAL Teams
and then as a civilian has another how
many years 20 in other so we're just
looking to the solid 50 years of service
to Naval Special Warfare the SEAL Teams
so like I said Rogers been on before now
one real quick story to kind of give a
little background as to Rogers attitude
about things and so I was on and I told
this part of the story last time we were
on a ship we were we were having our our
operation already this exercise was
being graded called an o re and the
person that's grating it is Roger Aden
sir you know the young seal platoons
were getting graded and making sure that
we know what we're doing and at this
point Roger is a Warrant Officer so he's
a commissioned officer and he's out on
the ship with us going you know watching
how we're planning and seeing how we're
preparing our gear and making sure that
we're we know what we're doing like I
said and as a commissioned officer
you're supposed to be eating in what's
called the ward room with the rest of
the officers so you know the military
has officers and they have enlisted guys
and the officers are so
the managers and the enlisted guys are
the workers and as an officer on a ship
on a navy ship you have something called
a ward room which is nice to have it's
just a little it's a smell you add a
little level up it's pretty darn nice in
the ward room I've eaten in both the
ward room and on the mess decks and the
ward room you know you have real civil
and there's actually people serving you
so the ward room is kind of nice well
Roger as a Warrant Officer is you know
permitted or authorized or supposed to
eat with the rest of the officers was
supposed to go get that good treatment
and Roger didn't want to eat with the
officers he wanted to eat with the chief
so then the middle management of the of
the Navy is the chief the chief petty
officers and there's Chiefs senior
Chiefs and master chiefs and they're
like the backbone of the Navy they have
the tactical knowledge and the SEAL
Teams and so Roger instead of wanting is
that our eating with the officers he
wanted to eat with the Chiefs
and before he was a Warrant Officer what
were you a senior chief before you were
worn off certainly masters off Master
Chief so he was a hot idea Master Chief
before he became a Warrant Officer and
so he started eating the Chiefs mess
with all the Chiefs well some of the
Chiefs on the ship they didn't like
having an officer you know I don't want
this officer here this is our territory
right this is our area again you know we
can't why is this officer coming in here
and so my platoon chief at the time was
actually friends with with Roger but you
know he was the guy that was getting had
really building relationships for the
Chiefs on the ship and all that stuff
and so they knew him and they and he was
a senior chief and they pulled him aside
they said hey you know hey senior chief
you know it's kind of we got this
warrant officers to see why is he coming
in he's not shouldn't be coming in here
he's nice Cody needs Cody up the ward
room with the rest of the officers this
is the Chiefs mess he doesn't belong in
here and so my chief was like listening
to him oh okay oh I'm not sure why you
feel that way but this goes on for a
couple days and finally my platoon chief
and I wasn't there for this but I got
told the story and my platoon chief was
a guy from this
Souths and he had a great accent and
talked in a very distinct manner and so
so they get into much I think it was
lunch they roll into the the Chiefs mess
for luncheon Warrant Officer Hayden
comes in and he's standing in there and
he's getting a couple looks from people
and finally my platoon chief stands up
and says uh can I ask everyone in here a
question real quick and they go okay you
know what what he says well this here is
Warrant Officer Roger Hayden member of
the underwater demolition teams member
of the SEAL team served three tours in
Vietnam highly decorated including a
Purple Heart for being wounded and he
was a master chief before he got
commissioned and he wants to eat with us
in the Chiefs mess does anyone here have
a problem with that and of course no one
did nothing but crickets and so Roger
Hayden eats with Roger Hayden want to
hit you so Roger
welcome to show once again thanks for
coming back and the last time we were
time constraint and you said you've come
back so here you are appreciate you
coming back on it's my pleasure thank
you and like I said anybody that wants
to get the full background you know
listen to podcast number thirty-seven
and he talks a little bit about how you
grew up but I had a question when you
joined so you came in and your dad was
UDT which is awesome and then when you
joined the Navy
in 1965 did you know you were going to
Vietnam was the war big enough yet cuz
we had this guy on last time captain
Charlie plumb and he went to the Naval
Academy and he he said he graduated from
the Naval Academy I think in 1965 as
well but he said he never heard he never
heard the word Vietnam one time while he
was going to Naval Academy it wasn't
until he graduated that the war
escalated and all of a sudden they
realized what he was going through
flight training that yeah you're going
to Vietnam but when you joined in 65 did
you know I mean were you thinking yeah
I'm definitely gonna go to war and go to
Vietnam yeah putting
much because I'd have been drafted in
the army and I knew the army is going to
Vietnam so I figured I knew I wanted to
go on the Navy and into utt my dad never
talked about it much but uh you know
when I was a younger I watched the
movies of the Marines attacking and
beachheads and getting mowed down you
know Rangers taking heavies and stuff
and then I saw the bridge of the River
Kwai and the Guns of Navarone
and I figured yeah if you're going to
fight if I can outfit you want to find
my sneak around a little bit more so
yeah I did I did fact as soon as I got
in to the Navy I I took the screening
test and all that stuff and you know
before I even went to know right after
when I was at radium in school I was a
rating winner so do it that was a twenty
two week long school and that's what I
did is I work and get all that stuff and
did the screen test and you know they
wanted me to go to rota or some other
Navy insulation because I didn't do too
bad in Radium school I wasn't the number
one guy but and I went now I'm going to
go to you TT and so and if you went to
what up that you yeah they we our class
our class was a certain up for about six
months so they stuck me on the USS Paul
Revere 32nd Street waiting for you GT
training and I was a designated seaman
back in the day a designated seaman was
pretty good wasn't like it is now and I
figured I'd working the Radio Shack or
something like that well as soon as they
checked the board they put me mess cook
and I was down accelerating when I went
down there there were two other guys
that were waiting for a 22 that were in
the scullery so we sat there and did
that for six months and got off the ship
and went next door across the bay there
to training yeah that's something the
Navy it's if you're a new guy everyone
talks about how new guys get treated
wherever you are as a military but in
the Navy when you go to show up to a
ship you doesn't matter you have to work
in the in the scullery which is washing
dishes what is it a 90 day stint you got
to do in the out pretty
yeah pretty much ninety days uh and and
you only don't do that
if you're an e4 debuff right and we did
I did employment where we had a guy that
was Annie SEO but he's an e3 and you
know he was saying hey wait how am I
going to get out of this you know doing
the skullery duty and we're like you're
not that's the rules you know you're
gonna go do it you can do it I was a
senior Keith two of us a guy named real
good friend of mine
we couldn't get a flight back so they
put us on an Arg to float back here to
San Diego and we kept all of our guys
from then the nest cook Network seaman
that's where he just went we got stuff
to do we're doing training and they
haven't got time to do that oh we kept
them out of course I was a senior Chiefs
in and so so we had a little pull yeah
plus they cover the boat he really liked
us a lot and you know they M the CMC and
he was a PBR Vietnam guys oh really long
really well yeah yeah well and actually
this kid ended up making e4 luckily
before we went on deployments care about
that but I really feel did bringing the
supplies and stuff like that you know
because it was a good workout yeah yeah
I forget what they call that unwrapped
unwrapped now we did that do ya we're
actually when I was on my first
deployment I deployed to Guam and you
know we just get whatever he wanted I
was 21 years old it was completely
insane you got all this per diem money
you felt like the richest you will never
mind felt like you were the richest guy
you ever met I mean you never made any
money when you're in 16 17 years old you
get in the SEAL Teams you're getting all
this money and then they go overseas and
they're giving you per diem and so
you're the richest dude in the world you
have very limited responsibilities
because you're a new guy in a seal
platoon so what do you do just get crazy
and get after it and you know you're
doing whatever you want and then my next
deployment was on a ship and we pull
into the first port and they say you
know he fallen below
Liberty expires at 10 o'clock and I was
like oh yeah whatever you know I'm a
seal they're like no actually you'll be
back on the ship at 10 o'clock and there
was no way around it you know what there
was ways around it we found ways around
you know the way around it was
I put my PT gear in a backpack and then
go off the ship
to go out whatever and then hang out all
night until five o'clock in the morning
and I put my PT gear back on I grunt get
it so I going to walk up the bow
whatever I was coming back again I was
just out for a run
got my rock on so there was ways sure
there's ways to make it happen
so speaking of guys from from when you
were going through training was there
guys when you're going through buds
training was there Korea Korean vet you
TT guys in there when world war two was
it just Vietnam guys of early anand our
instructors yeah older World War two
guys it was one guy named Tom Demming
Tom great big tall guy who cut
and and he was a world war two unique
let me tell you the story on that guy so
we're out uh we just get to thank
committee the last part of the training
you know third phase you know so we're
all lined up there we just got off we
went out there on an LCU you know with
all of our demo enamel and all that
other crap we just mustered out there
and this guy comes walking up great big
tall guy rolled what was I in 1918 you
don't mean he looked probably like you
do or I do we thought it was an old guy
he look I yeah but he looks at us he
starts talking you know he goes
goddamnit I'm the I'm your demo
instructor and keeps talking he says
that'll brook no bullshit on the ranges
you know we're kind of just looking at
him like what the hell he gets himself
worked up a little bit and he goes
matter of fact anybody that screws up
would just go out behind the shitter and
get it scored away you know and work
still looking he talks a little bit more
and gets himself all excited and shit
and he goes matter-of-fact anybody wants
a guy behind the shitter right now we'll
go you know and if we just look at
welcome to find out later on was in the
82nd airborne and jumped into Norman
called
got captured escaped on and on then he
was in the Korean War two that was one
of our instructors almost all of them
there were in the Korean War you know
pretty much but uh and we had another
guy
and on his jacket he wore yadda
UDT instructor and the other side was
God you know he was he was a hook-nosed
Indian Apache and he was a badass dude
man that's some great guys and now most
of the instructors yeah were in summer
Vietnam guys you know like had this one
blue eyed guy he was
I can't think his name right now either
but he was on vacation was paddling up
north in the Columbia River sup no not
that North the East Coast I deny his key
was on an excursion with some other
people on his canoe tipped over and he
it was real cold and she had and he was
trying to swim a couple in the shorten
shit and just just went out but this guy
would run behind you and you of course
we didn't have a lot of hair but what we
had to stood up you know and you turn
and look and they were he was just
staring at she had these blue eyes you
know I'll think it was naming a minute
real good guy though and it there must
have been because blood was pretty
regimented now but they must hadn't no
it was it was definitely less regimented
when I went through for sure they must
have been completely just like no rules
when you went through you know we this
guy
during hell week he had what they called
the swimmer line and like to say we're
on the base I'd remind you we're in
training in January started 3 January
some colder than God you know what he
would do is will he'd have us hook into
what we call the flutter board line you
know like you when you do recon as the
guys hold on the line you move down the
line and stuff and he'd send us all out
and he'll there's about fucked about 60
of us excuse me that's about XD that's
what we did send us out and we had to be
in a straight line if we weren't it
bring us all back and line us all up
again and we weren't straight so he sent
us out again brought us all back in and
we're freezing the guys are almost
getting hypothermia because we're not or
just in a ke pocket not you know regular
utilities that you were for training
yeah so he sent us out again the third
time and like if you're on the bitter
end line your food you then he brought
us back in he goes wow goddamn I guess
it still wasn't very you guys still
weren't in a straight line and we mean
we're gonna have to send you out again
all the way down the line all you heard
was click click click click click click
click click we just looked at him
well alright we got other things to do
that was it we were done and everybody
had lost a whole class that was so cold
if you've always if you don't know
California and you think California's
like they watch the old TV show you
think the water's all warm it's not warm
it's not one especially in January yes
January 3rd it's not going to be warm
and and you were saying you guys were
swimming like crazy going through that
because you knew that you're going to
UDT and so you're a frog man that's a to
be entering for not seals so we did a
lot more water work and you guys did
going to buds because we didn't have the
seal portion when we got that but after
we made our deployment came back went
and seal team then you went into CAD
razor did you get any land warfare at
all and but oh yeah I loved it it was
normalizing yeah basic stuff and little
immediate IEDs but immediate action goes
not much it was like our last op that we
had I think I told you this and uh thank
you many was we did swimmer Scouts in on
the other side of a rock formation we
called birdshit Rock and got the island
they gave us off a 40-pound haversacks
and we went from there all the way 23
miles of the island we blew up something
walking yeah okay so you humped 23 miles
and swam over the beach yeah and then
came back and attacked the camp that was
our last op nein
that's a that's a crappy patrol two
dozen tactus yeah I know that that's a
no I was small I was thought it was
pretty smart see so I wore a kind of a
wetsuit what do you call that the small
one you know like a wetsuit on top and
because I you know so I wouldn't freeze
to death come in and actually this was
April almost the end of April and it was
still cold out of saying committee you
know we swam in and I humped with that
thing on all the way up there and it got
sunny and warm
I almost friggin died by the time my
back you could peel it off me like this
you know yeah there's no good there's no
good way to do it there's like no good
way to handle coming over the beach it's
not going to be convenient you're not
going to be comfortable that's one of
the things that makes in my opinion
that's one of the things that makes the
SEAL team the guys missile team is
really good is that we just have to deal
with the water and as soon as you're
deal in the water like you just said
there's no easy way to do that it's like
you're going to be there be freezing in
the water or gonna be sweating on land
or you're going to be too hot or no I
see you're not you're gonna be okay in
the on the on the land it you're just
screwed is what I'm saying and not to
mention your weapons your weapons all
get your radios all get jacked up your
your weapons all get jacked up your gear
gets all jacked up you got sand in your
boots there's no good way to deal with
it and on top of that the communications
like you're in the water you can't talk
to people you can't there's nobody
radios aren't work and it just
everything sucks and so when we were do
off dry it just seems like it's so easy
to do and I think that's one big thing
that separates it doesn't separate us
but it's one of the things that makes us
good
that we have to deal with the water and
we deal with it our whole bottom line is
you should never bring a boat to shore
you always swim in yep that's what we do
you know just like swimmer Scouts the
whole nine yards yep that's the bottom
line was a chief that's pretty hard on
that stuff we never brought the boats
ashore yeah you know we we did the same
thing when we were in the article tune
we never brought the boats in because
there's a there's a 10 15 maybe 20
percent chance that you're going to flip
the boat you're going to lose a boat
something's going to happen to boat and
then you're screwed
now you got a boat washing up against
the shore and you got to deal with it
it's big no we always it's a big it's a
big target there for sure for sure like
an in Desert Storm you know we inserted
those Kuwait ease the officer I won't
mention any names but wanted to bring
both the boats in you know and into
quate and let the quiddity guys off and
I went nice keep at least if you're
going to do that keep one boat back you
if you keep another boat and sure
because they can give covering fire you
know yeah and then if they have to any
and you know you can be seen I don't
mean if that's a big target you know to
me you just don't do that you know know
that that's there's so many things you
got to figure out what the water and
when you when you guilt was I mean
that's why when we were in Iraq and we
rarely did boat ops we did some in in
the river but you just don't either on
footage and everything is so much easier
it's crazy it's crazy
the you get so you get done with
training saenko two-mile 1967 you get
done with training and you check into
UDT 12 and you didn't really know too
much about the same things I guess no
one at that time knew much about this
early not much at all and you were
saying on that first podcast that we did
that the platoons were really formed up
yet you kind of showed up at UDT and
your kids it's it's kind of a loose
situation but you do do a workup so once
we start working up and it was
regimented you know you knew how to do
but we had a while they had just come
back and relieved uvt 11 and just
deployed and then 12 came back and you
have a kind of a stand down move about a
month or two oh so we'll show that for
ya okay because it's a nine-month
deployment for you TTS
so you have a lot of six months work up
and then you have three months for the
guys going leave
like that we came I came in just at that
time so it was really kind of like we'd
go up and do what they call silver
slippers up at Pendleton when the
Marines are doing piteous landings and
we'd be the lifeguards and stuff like
that you don't need until we start
forming up for the hard work and then
Augusta got pretty good what did you
guys do was that when a hardcore about
PT back then oh yeah
would you guys do teen pts yep platoons
our team team the whole team yep and
what every every everyday was it the
same was it
flutter kicks push-ups yeah I'll just
your basic PT in fact I didn't start
lifting weights until said I was in
about 15 years maybe 16 17 years because
you do Old Course swimming all the PT we
had and everything we were in really
good shape you know I mean and you
didn't see a lot of the guys in the gym
lifting heavy and stuffs I came on later
on then also which I changed was later
on was a chief and senior chief and
stuff and even now not as an LPL we
still did platoon PT every morning but
we do it every other day then let the
guys go off and do their running to do
their PT of weightlifting and stuff like
that no work out well you know you can
change even though I thought PT in the
morning first thing is the best to do
yeah especially when we were su V can I
have two guys would be throwing up and
shuffling MPT yeah I always liked least
at team one when I got the team one
there was that that team PT we did every
day and team two is the same thing but
you know I'll tell you once the war
started there's a lot less focus on PT
and it just was well I'm saying it's on
where you are too chuckle you never to
go for long runs and shit we're in a
rock in jail yeah we'd run around
Mason's but did you guys have a my my
question is the did you take weights
with you did you have a workout places
up yet we deployed and actually once one
team shows up somewhere on deployment
but they all bring a bunch of gear yeah
and
and there's enough to do it get it done
and then other teams they don't have to
bring everything but they'll bring more
stuff and eventually you know whatever
compound hearing is pretty nice if you
go to that same calm down yeah and and I
was bribe brought mats for for jiu-jitsu
I'd make a little jujitsu area so I
could total course so I could still
train and get the boys training and you
know what's fighters like you were
talking about its we have some of this
stuff stays if you're talking about
walking around in UDT shorts and coral
boots and unfortunately nudity shorts I
don't think guys wear I don't think they
get issued him anymore but when I got
the team one we absolutely got issued
DDT choice and that's work that was our
uniform and we got issued coral booties
those old clay coral booties and I
didn't realize you know that's what you
guys want I mean let somebody thing yeah
probably been issued for I don't know II
went outta town you see guys with coral
advising their Rolex watch and stuff you
know to me he can pick out a team kinda
harsh II yeah I was uh I was I looked I
looked up Coral booties and I was just
saying if anybody makes them any more
they're hard to get their on eBay you
got to buy a pair of ebay you got to be
lucky if they have your size I'm going
to go through my gear and see if I still
have my coral booties but and then you
did do a legit workup though where you
did all your hydro recon oh yeah well
recons
like up the coast by Pendleton we drug
this one rocket looking thing in up over
these fucking mountains and put it in
Lake and stuff like that and then we
swam across the wow did we flip no we
didn't right there at the channel and it
goes out and have those old gun
emplacements it wet it with tackles and
I had them set up a booby traps and
stuff so we'd go across and work her way
up and shit like that always stuff yeah
in UDT it was it wasn't bad it was good
training I mean but it wasn't you know
just like a story I told you it was
during the 67 68 Ted we're in donk am on
the a scary and that's where who I was
was UDT and there were about 17 of us on
there we're doing that dark
thing later on getting that a little bit
more but that's when we worked with the
9th inventory and stuff and uh anyway
had a seal platoon in Mito which wasn't
too too far away but it was right in the
town why these coasts would have a would
have a their place in a town I'd never
know because anytime you left her when
any work you know I'm saying that you
can be picked out but anyway so they
were almost getting over an but they
were on the tallest building that a57
quarters rifle and stuff anyway sent a
call-out hey we need help
number 17 of us you know on the ice
carry EDT guys we wanted to go in and
rescue them and save them and our
officer just a great guy lieutenant said
now you ain't going anywhere
we're so close you got in there how a
Coptic we're not going to go we just
want to join help me out you know people
are incarcerated oh yeah you know
they're seals but the NDT guys so anyway
so um we didn't do that and I got back
in deployment when the SEAL team went to
the Kadri and I know guys those guys by
the way they didn't get overrun no they
they brought along they were coming up
the stairways never throwing grenades
down that and when stuff like that and
finally the Arve and the u.s. came in
and took me go back over it was doing a
67 68 to go bad but anyway so when I got
back and I went through Kadri and stuff
I found out you know hey we weren't
ready for this we didn't know any
immediate action drills well not a lot
not a time if not you know pounded in
your head where we'd automatically think
about him you know any urban environment
whatsoever fiance plus we were in urban
and that was urban would add our asses
handed to me yeah that was we didn't
know we were fighters would have fought
but you know figure those guys in me
told the VC and stuff there they had
their shit together that was their
talent stuff you know me with a yeah you
know more about the urban stuff than I
do because I never fought urban you know
we hit who which is and stuff like that
but we never swept through we did one
village one time but it was you know it
was good you know I mean
yeah and Zoey when you deploy to with
UDT did you guys ride a ship over there
do you fly over there how'd you get to
Vietnam we flew over to Subic Bay and
like I said that's where we were at
that's like you went to Guam well sue
because our place okay
and then they would would fly over to we
had different debts that we had in
Vietnam like in Danang Ned camped in
Shaw and from the Nang you'd work up and
round Phu Bai wake when creed uncle the
northern part of the area and stuff you
know and then we got on the dye chinko
and I don't know if we picked the
duchenko up at Subic or not we might
have you know when we did olden Beatrice
ons and then the next day I went to was
down in dong town on me and you go back
to Subic in-between at all oh yeah oh
really and we'd be there for about a
month and or three weeks and so we had
attack we deploy from Subic out to
vietnam do operations for a month and go
back three months Oh every month we got
three months at a time yeah although
it's a nine month deployment yeah so
yeah we my three debts were Danang and
on the dye chinko and then down in
downtown when I was in unity that was
three months and each places and first
of all the on the last one you thought
talked about doing 130 miles worth of
beach mean I was about 120 I think you I
was a lot on at ten mij was three months
but you know you were kind of talking
about it like oh you know we were doing
this recon but that was you you were
reconning beaches in north vietnam
you know south south vietnam and was
there any resistance were you guys in
jeopardy of getting rolled up or was it
more of like almost an admin thing or
was it somewhere in between oh we we
always had these the Marines or the
Arvin which was the South Vietnamese
army they would screen put screens out
when we do the beaches to cover us in
case we got hit with anything right
because they were nobody knew what was
really on the beaches and stuff but if
the Marines are in the area they attend
a patrol and they'd worked the back
backyard and stuff as we're doing our
recon
the one I've told you I we got hit was
we didn't have any armored army or
Marines so we sent two of our guys in
the back to kind of check things out as
we're doing a recon and that's what we
got cotton had almost gotten that
l-shaped ambush and what happened was as
we were coming down the beach and we had
the guys out and I was a good talker
first I was out front with another guy
and I had a pair of agency UT keys on
coral booties and my super slate and I
was writing The Bachelor information but
so everyone knows what we're talking
about when you're going to land people
on beaches or if you're potentially
going to land people on beaches you have
to do a reconnaissance of the beach but
not just of the beach itself but up the
water and how deep the water is and make
sure there's no obstacles in there and
so the people that did this since World
War two was the underwater demolition
teams so that's what we're talking about
the way you do it is you have a
literally you have a line a big rope
it's small it's more like a line than it
is rope but that stretches from the
beach from a couple guys on the beach
called the beach party all the way out
to a boat a small little rubber boat
well sometimes yeah and then that was an
IPS we hooked it to it's about 30 feet
it has knots where you know each pair is
going to be holding on to and you mark
take the sounding then you as you went
to the next sounding which is 25 yards
down the beach and on the b-side be
holding up these markers so that you
could get yourself on them you'd be
definitely doing down until you got to
that point again then you take your
sound again then you come back and make
a hydrographic chart so there's guys on
the beach that are holding for what we
call range markers and they said what is
that like 10 yards apart look at one guy
in the front one guy in the back and
they're looking at a compass so that
they're making sure that they're lined
up so that lines up this whole line so
it's this it's this kind of complicated
and it seems like an administrative
thing but you got to do it otherwise you
know you get a situation where the
Marines come into land and they hit up
like they do yeah like they did in
Tarawa and they you know big they hit a
reef and then they dropped the ramps the
guys get out and they didn't know that
that reef was only ten feet long it's
two feet deep but now on the other side
of the reefster guys going into ten
twelve fifteen feet of water and drowned
so that's why you have to actually be
fairly precise or at least as precise as
you can be when you're taking these when
you're doing this hydrographic
reconnaissance you know you have the
back shore party you know the two guys
there I have the officer and a couple
other guys picking up the steaks put
mistakes out and that's usually katara
first job you're way out ahead of
everybody else taking the bachelor
information so when you come back and do
your under graphic chart you know you
can lay it out exactly then you have to
do it Leroy I was a photographer I know
all the kids so which I hate it because
you had to man make hand draw the maps
your hand drawn that and those those are
those charts that you draw you're going
to present those are going to get
presented to you know the the Navy and
they're going to use those charts to
conduct this landing so like I said they
got to be good got to be good quality
yeah anyway so the other two guys are
walking along and we were doing or beach
reconnaissance and everything well they
had an l-shaped ambush on us and they
had a spider hole back here with a
couple guys that once we got hit and if
anybody ran back these guys that holds
them down why are two guys hit those two
guys nice spider hole and opened up on
him which made them open up on the
sooner so we all leapfrog back down the
beach
really great guy i meter charge
everything was perfect we grabbed him to
the line the boat IDs took off and you
know 9 or 9 and a half horsepower engine
didn't go real fast you know then we had
a Coast Guard Cutter out there they
started lobbing in Willie Peter on him
but we didn't know it was them and some
of it landed pretty close to us we
thought that was them
do we not trying to hit us and we got
out far enough in our PL that we finally
got to and got on Appeals uh you know
the boat that the that we inserted off
of him stuff and they picked us up in
the guy and was shooting his 50 and
stuff but what was really neat was
income these two jets oh and they napalm
the whole beach that was that was kind
of cool that's when I told you when I
got back to the boat I said screw this
naked warrior shift yeah
jockeys are you're in a pair of UDT ZV
coral booties or any that's like what
reefs workers a little they're like
they're like Chuck Converse Chuck
Taylors yeah a little bit leaner you
have the split no no it was they're like
yeah it's like color coral would so you
could walk on Coral yeah yeah get cut
with it like hold you down there that
big thing no no they were like they were
like they were canvas and they had a
kind of a real thick rubberized bottom
on it today yeah they were good and I
had an m79 so I'm shooting that thing as
I'm running back and that's the only
weapon you had is it yes all I had yeah
that your your slate could draw on and
collect back short semester yeah that
was kind of exciting and with that
before you was that was that recon
before you work with a 9th Infantry yeah
yeah okay I went from there from the dye
Schenkel down to dong Tam and work with
a 9th infantry and the the 9th infantry
man so this stuff I was looking about
you know a lot the 9th in securing what
they did and so just first of all the
9th infantry is the is the unit that the
fictional character
Forest Gump was supposed to be attached
to which is why in the movies working by
the water and all that stuff I imagine
that's what they that's why they
that the 9th infantry in Vietnam had 10
Medal of Honor awarded to soldiers and 3
sailors so they were working in
conjunction very closely with the
brown-water Navy which again to pull a
quote from the last time you you were on
Roger you're like saying that job as
being brown-water Navy was just vicious
John I wish John and general
Westmoreland said that the 9th Infantry
Division and the mobile riverine forces
saved the Delta region from falling to
the North Vietnamese during during Tet
that could have been I mean I didn't I
wasn't on land with them don't know
everything they did remember I was a
second class in and we got we were on
the ass the ass carryin been a wall as
reconnaissance guys with the asker
indented when they were APD's what's
that
amphibious some some kind of an
amphibious ship yeah both homework big
ones and troop ships well data troops I
think the a scary was a tube ship I'm
not sure it could have been the Benoit -
but they were pretty good-sized ships
and they were right at on the who right
at Don cam which was the Dong Tamworth
had a big army base and a Navy base and
late my third trip to Vietnam I went
back there was a seal and it was a same
same place of the same area so when you
how did you guys get linked up with the
9th Infantry well we that's who we're
doing the reconnaissance for to see if
they could go up the canals and up the
rivers you know and see what the death
was so they could bring the brown water
Navy out there that the troop carriers
and stuff like that for the 9th Infantry
and they didn't know what the depth of
some of the places they were going to go
in so they dropped us off on these we
call them the darts
they were like a jet ski right except
you didn't sit up on me laid down on
them use your feet to guide them and
they had a 355 degree camera and a
fathometer and they would take two of us
up drop us off and we'd come down and do
the reconnaissance I mean take soundings
and
pictures of gnomes point like a pagoda
or another canal coming in or something
you know we'd come back we'd do a chart
and we'd give it to them and that's what
they used those charts to go up and do
their impervious landings and if anybody
could only go up those down those things
maybe once or twice then you didn't do
it again because they'd be waiting for
you so when we weren't doing that which
you can only do so many of them and we
started writing with the 9th infantry as
their demo guys and and so you would
would you have already seen it because
you do the dart mission and then you'd
come back and then they'd come up with
their plan and then they'd say okay
we're going to go up that River that you
just came down and so you'd be from we
would you be familiar with it now no
they took us we went up to four corners
in the places that we'd never been okay
that was deep enough for him to go up
and stuff but uh they might have I don't
know you know that would have been John
oldish my ot that would have probably
been in on the planning when they were
going to go in some and talk about our
charts and sir I know remember I just a
booger-eater just one of the guys in the
darts you know and and but then they
said okay we're going to need you over
the log I know you were saying on the
last podcast that they had these log
dams that
oh yeah they'd put dams across logs and
the stop the boats up and just different
obstacles and shit or bunkers along and
now we'd go in and blow up the bunkers
or brought the log dams you know if they
had them and that's what I said they
first put us on what they called an
alpha boat which was the lead boat and
they had one of the rare and one of the
front and what would they look like
um not I don't have a picture over I can
show you that I actually I anybody
looking looks up on the night inventory
they'll be able to see yeah
anyway the Alpha boat we're on one of
those and that's the one I told you we
got sunk on because of e-40 rock and hit
us fighting the exhaust and things
started going down and we went ashore if
it been a little bit higher to hit all
those stacks of c4 we had so but and
then they started putting us in about
the 3rd or 4th boat back that's because
they didn't want this big demo yeah we
did in the front alcoho
yeah that makes sense pretty much ended
that one out so your boat gets hit with
a rocket and it starts sinking and in
the was it like achi front of the boat
I was could have been I just know her
first logic so yeah and they ran us up
didn't start sinking down and we got off
their little perimeter and then the a
zipper bolt came up and just holds
everything down and we swam over the
simple Bolton got off the Zippo boat
it's so named because after the Zippo
lighter because as a flame thrower yes
right directly out of I I know I popped
this stuff off like people know what it
is it hadn't been there to see it but I
mean it came zipping up and then we swam
over to it and we got on it and got out
of it and he got everyone out of there
was yeah nobody got hurt or killed on
that just that b40 rocket they started
opening up at our the boats opened up to
and they they had 50s you know Jesus
Christ 20 what did you try and salvage
and he's a demo just leave it well
actually would you blow it we were going
to come back and do that but they
decided to have you OD do it so he went
back and blew the boat up and all that
crap so yeah because it was just partly
out of the water and stuff but they'd be
on pista software underwater demolition
was like you know WTF you know yeah
that's what we do really well the UD
guys I guess they didn't have a lot to
do so they sent them down there I don't
know for his army or Navy EOD but no no
it's always good to blow things up
that's one oh yeah my first deployment
to Iraq we didn't blow very much up and
when I went to my second deployment to
Iraq I kind of had the attitude as if we
had the opportunity to blow something up
we were going to blow it up seems like
the smart thing to do they never take it
apart hip in place and load and play and
that one you know on the last podcast
you were talking about that one
operation that you went on and you it
was basically a giant ambush against the
whatever seven or eight votes that you
guys had that the 9th infantry had and
they must have been prepared waiting for
you got furred for this group to show up
and were they was the enemy that well
organized at that point I wouldn't say
well organized but you know when you got
psyops guys dropping pamphlets in saying
you know we may be doing something
that's
you know all the good guys leave and
stuff like that you know psyops had a
lot to play with that or the choppers
going around with her speakers and you
know to me yeah so yeah that particular
when there was another group of boats
that went up ahead of us dropped off
their guys the 9th infantry were coming
back and we passed him and since we got
by him I'd say about 10 minutes and we
got opened up on they didn't yet the
first group they just hit our group and
you know that was a that was a bad day
in Dodge City but it you know got hit
really bad but managed to get to the
shore and put some of the guys off and
stuff and it was I think it was going to
be a pincher movement where they came
hell fire people because they go up the
other guys way off and there were three
UDT guys on that group and then there
was three of us on the group that when
we got hit and your main mission was
going to be demo if yeah basically yeah
but you know those are those big it's
weird it's just like straight up
amphibious operations the army conducted
you know think about that and the
Marines are holding the DMZ yeah yeah
you were saying that the Marines were
busy upholding the DNA at that time yeah
and it kind of blew me away that the 9th
Infantry did a good job and they were
fighters you know they were out of
Washington state of Washington you know
and they they were good good tooth yeah
um what about another different
difference I mean even with the 9th
Infantry those guys I mean in UDT you
guys are all volunteers and I mean and
you've said you would have been drafted
had you not joined what did you did you
notice any difference between drafted
guys and guys that were volunteers
didn't really work with that many army
guys in the 9th Infantry the only thing
I can remember that stands out as I had
a 2nd lieutenant come up to me when I
was on a riverboat one of the river
boats they're about ready to land him
and he came up to me with his map and
asked me where he was you know and that
kind of went
that's a second lieutenant she's leading
uh you know platoon or squad of guys in
you know that kind of you know I'm
saying I just don't know I don't know my
thought of that was is we were trained
and we knew what we were going to do
just like in SEAL team and we lean
forward and that's what we're going to
do you just picked off the street go
through basic training and then you you
know next thing you know you're up on a
hill and Vietnam being over and stuff
that's got to be pretty traumatic you
know but then again Americans are
Americans we fly you know ii mean
regardless but i think we were more
psychologically set for what we did then
you're because of the extra training we
had and stuff plus the guys that trained
us we're a lot of more vietnam guys and
like i said second world war in korean
that gives you with the type of job they
did that's what we do you got wounded on
that mission - yeah right how about did
you get wounded just some shrapnel my
footing my leg no big thing
did you did you take you out of the
field for no not at all fact i got up
and started shooting along this guy this
other guy I thought we had this buddy of
ours I think I told us he got hit really
bad for slapping on his arms and legs
and I calls over to him after I move my
fingers and toes and everything realized
that we all got blown down and then I
went over to him hit him with morphine
put it through his collar then the
thirty gunner got blown off his gun so I
got to start shooting a 30-year me no
big thing that's just what you do you
know yeah we ran everything so yeah so
you check back what I would ask he got
blown on the other side of him and calls
over to him didn't see my pin to his
collar so hits him with another shot of
morphine you know yeah in about four or
five minutes he kind of setup like this
is one to do something but he was he was
scoot y'all sir really bad and and you
got up and start shooting and stuff and
the guys that were down and everything
were after I don't thirty ran out of
ammo I start shooting 16s and they hand
this up 16s a shoot and stuff floating
forces hit and then like I said the ramp
went down we started going in towards
beach to let the guys that want wounded
get off and we started taking fire right
through the front so I went to one side
we went to the other side and I was
using m79 to try to suppress fire and
stuff and we backed off and we got out
of there
did you insert any of the army guy yeah
about eight or nine of them yeah and how
big how many guys got inside of those
like a company a company strength yeah
not yet smaller company it was eight
boats a lot of people about he can put
about 25-30 goats here yeah we were here
we like I said it was really a weird
thing because we're sitting in and
everything just our fire going off and
we heard number one boats hit
we're number four bald you know we're
number three number four yeah number two
boats hit number three boats hit and I
remember I just turned and looked at and
said we're fucked
and we got hit and what it did is it has
a canvas cover and they had all those
wire stretchers stacked up and the b40
rocket was heading right towards the the
conning tower you know I mean earlier
driving and everything but it went low
and hit those stretchers and it just
went grew you know all that shit went
out so did you guys get good medical
training I mean obviously knew how to
give morphine well UDT yeah it was
pretty good but in a SEAL team we had
extensive mental medical training factor
first Platoon I went over is a we had
our first class corpsman probably the
best every week he had run a suit seven
rather with soggy head wounds or
something sucking chest wounds and with
the same stuff that you guys did have
the mannequins up in the wood and you'd
have to run up and treat him and what to
do and we learned to give ourselves
serum albumin in case the corpsman was
hit or something you need to give
yourself an ID we did all that stuff
yeah all of us carry that with us
everybody had certain well bunam which
is a blood volume expander keynote I
mean just in case you haven't but you TT
not so much
we need morphine drone use a basics so
of the basics and you know pressurize
and tourniquets and stuff like that but
not not real real good in utt they do a
good job with that T Triple C
classification ow
the factory 84 forgiving his hands or
but you can do it combat trauma yeah
guys learned that and so they know what
to do when somebody gets hit everybody
in the patina knows like a decent amount
to get the guy stable like told us and
protune this is the one on 69 he says
yeah I'm the only corpsman year and if I
get hit somebody's got to take care of
me yeah he wider search good good for
him
so you get home from that deployment and
now like you said you you knew you had
enough the naked warrior stuff and you
said I want to get a big machine gun but
I will say that was one of the best
appointments I was on the guys and
everything the UDT 12 at that time was
comprised of class 40 41 and 42 and
summer 43 but everybody knew everybody
you know I mean it was real tight and
real good and Subic Bay would put along
to shame oh sure wish yeah I guess after
we've been there for about three weeks
you're ready to go to a yeah their debt
just to get out there you go to Vietnam
to stand right yeah pretty much no I
never realized that you guys would go
back to you know back to to the day in
the middle of deployment that's that's
yeah well we would for then you'd head
off to your next kid like to say we were
there for nine months and each day was
about three months you know I mean maybe
a little less but we'd have some
downtime and see we can then we deal
with our next debt which is pretty nice
you know nine months is a long time but
still you know then actually back in the
day CB day was almost worse than Vietnam
in some areas because it was almost like
the gangsters back in Chicago you had
all these different gangs where after
each other to shed me when you're just
walking down next I thought you almost
had to look around the corner to see if
you know they were shooting at each
other before you walked by and shit it
was a was pretty uh kind of like the
wild wild west and you said that the
whole UDT 12 at that time was made up of
all guys from the same
like five or six months ago guys that
were there - from the other classes but
it was a the majority of us that were
put into platoons and suffer from class
40:39 maybe the athlete I was ahead of a
safe mode a lot of them went out some
went to 12 - they just put him 11 before
you went to a UDT team right and then
yeah a lot of more guys that were you
know behind us but remember we only ran
two classes a year but no kidding you
know two classes a year yeah because 39
was graduated and then we started 40
okay and then we graduated and that's
when 41 was starting you know I mean
what do they run now like 5 yeah
something like that 5 6 it was something
like 5 when I went through yeah I think
so
so you had a good experience with UDT
but you still wandering oh yeah I'm glad
to go to me and I got him we put in the
chit everyone to go to seal team and
they yelled at us and said yeah none to
get back you know so when we got back
we're the first two out of you Takeda
CAD Drake that's awesome and I was you
know echo and I had a conversation I was
talking about how at COP one when I was
in training cells tilting when we called
ourselves cadre and I didn't really know
where that came from but I knew that
that was what it was called and we were
proud that we are Cod rest but then I
was listening to do the podcast that you
you came on and you were talking about
Cochran you guys actually called a cadre
training that's what xqt was yeah was
cloudberry yeah guys that taught her
were Cogley instructors and that just
carried on a Clarion 14 training was
different you know once you got in your
gut at a sqt or Cadbury then you went to
a platoon and he went to platoon turning
- and that was still ran by some of the
cadre and Licata yeah because we had our
own train 71 team one training cells
been around that long run it was yeah
yeah that was the only team that's sure
it wasn't another team it was UDC guys
single guys yeah that work up or or the
cadre training now you started getting
heavy with field craft with I mean oh
everything yeah all every ambushes you
name it and then we had the element
ever we were done and the element River
is a lot like Vietnam they actually set
up a whole thing there to look like a
village they had a little wooden outpost
were that you know at the whole nine
yard you have to work you'll go down get
in and then work your way in and stuff
and it was just like Vietnam it was
pretty close and that once again the
people that are teaching you are F seals
that are in cadre now who probably just
got back from Vietnam so they got fresh
information from the back they are very
go to training our training 71 every
time a platoon came back they'd pull two
or three of the best guys from that
platoon and put him into our training so
and that was every platoon that came
back they did that so he had a crosscut
of all the different areas of Vietnam
and guys that had been in there that did
well not that's who I keep doing good
guys like and just some great guys I
mean we got good training and I mean
there was no bullshit because they knew
we knew that what we learned there was
going to save our asses in our buddies
butts so we got pounded into our heads
we did River and stream crossing a lot
because you had a lot of rivers and you
know small canals well not small canals
but pretty good-sized either walked on
the run up the other side or you went
across them you know like as a 60 gunner
I always carried about 3 UD T's with me
to help me fold across but I'm just
saying you had to judge the curve right
so when you went out it would bring you
right in where you're supposed to be and
stuff like that you know I mean just a
extensive training the Alamo rivers not
real it's a not a real fast-moving
stream but it has a good current and so
you learned all that you know you know
you learned what you had to have your
gear you had like we do a swimming-pool
stuff whether 60s is yet to see where we
needed to have the flotation and stuff
like that you know I mean it was pretty
good actually when I went out to Niland
we didn't even have the camp out there
we had in island itself the town there
was a gas station
it had about four or five green little
green trailers and that's where we
stayed at
and then they truck us up to where the
canal was a huge and stuff a lot of
times we'd go up there then we'd run
back and stuff you know what I mean and
we'd go up to chocolate mountains up to
Beall wells and stuff like that for
ambushes and just you know I mean we had
no camp the window camp their life and
siphon what was that sighs I can't
remember the cycle right I mean all
along the whole area in fact later on or
has implications that would be going to
talk about and come back some other way
and you'd still see holes were forty
mike-mike it would into stuff you know
from back in the how much how much work
were you doing at night oh that's all
the only time we worked every Monday we
do our media action drills and stuff
during the day and stuff but all of our
ambushes and all the other field graph
that we did and everything was all at
night because that's when we worked and
that was the that was the known thing it
was like yep we're gonna go out at night
that's what we do pretty much you know
how much did you guys did you guys go
out if there was a full moon would you
go out less in Vietnam would you go out
less if there's a full moon and because
you had foliage and stuff you couldn't
see that well it was still dark enough
you know sometimes in a desert a full
moon it's almost like beta oh yeah yeah
yeah and what you know you're talking
about gear a little bit what you carried
and there's all these kind of myths
about what guys were doing work in the
day and in in Vietnam one of them is
blue jeans like everyone wore blue jeans
or a lot a lot of guys wore blue jeans
which kind of makes sense to me because
they're tough right that was the whole
reason was the mosquitos you can go
through them and if you're in mangroves
and stuff it wouldn't tear them and
stuff rip stop would tear and if you
bend down like you wouldn't you stopped
and stuff excuse me each alive right to
the RIP stop and stuff so we started
wearing the blue jeans and you wanted to
get zip up blue jeans not to button up
because they also kept leeches bugs if
you had to budge button button up ones
you were screwed and then sometimes we
wore pantyhose underneath that to keep
leeches off it but would take the Levi's
and put them into our jungle boots and
riggers tape them around so you know we
did it wouldn't just be hanging down
where shit could come up and so
because there are a lot of leeches over
there no big thing but I mean you just
you just learned you know like I say the
penny hose that's pretty funny because
we were on see folk don't guys would be
walking around with pink and blue and
yellow pantyhose on stuff and satyrs are
giving us kind of some weird looks and
shit the cut of funny how about guys
going barefoot well we had a couple guys
that do that and guys stepped on stuff
and injured themselves and that I didn't
see that very much at all myself in my
platoons maybe other platoons okay yeah
yeah that was a big thing but a lot of
times we don't walk on trails we walked
outside of the trails and there's all
kinds of shit in there and you don't
want to just be there for it I guarantee
you so you get done with that workup and
everything how about how about like your
your your pig gunner hired stories about
guys taken every round out of their belt
and lubing every individual round
especially stole I heard that about
stoner Gunners that they take every
round out of their belt and lube every
individual round and put it back in
there Zach not sure I've never seen that
happen and we had four guys that carried
the stoner machine gun in my last
platoon but I don't know why you'd take
him out and put him back in yeah they
jammed a lot but that was just a stoner
thing we sent our guys to cadillac gage
which is who made this door so they
could learn all the intricacies and what
to do if something happened here I mean
the big guns
the sexy you didn't have to worry about
it that much as long as you took care of
that baby it did work for you anytime I
ever had a malfunction was operator
error
you know Oh kind of like having a slide
down your arm got Hannah you get a link
stuck in there or your human ear you
have your do-rag around your neck and it
gets caught in circulation I guess just
in range you learn you know I don't know
who told me one ball one of Vietnam
SEALs told me the story that like he had
the D yes oh he's a STONER gunner and
when he came back he checked in his
weapon and he was going and joined
another platoon sir
went to get a new stoner not a new
stoner but one of the stoners out of the
armory and he got wind check the stoner
out of the armory and are engraved in
the buttstock of the stoner it said
everybody must get stoned which I always
got a good ol bag that could have been I
was but that 60 it was just and you
developed exactly like my basic load was
about 6:30 because we had a hundred
thirty round box okay yeah we had China
Lake made that goes went right on the
side of it and we slung it you know and
shot it from the hip but after shooting
thousands of rounds from from the hip
you get really good I the barrel
coordination of exactly where that round
was going to go but even regardless you
always worked it in because it wasn't a
young sound excuse me a point weapon
like a m14 you know it was it's an area
weapon but still you can get pretty
accurate with that son of a bitch and
you'd always walk your rounds in because
what you know rounds well Shane off
could hit a guy just as well as get him
right square in his chest or something
and I use canteen pouches and carry five
cam team canteen pouches around my waist
and I put a hundred rounds there and
leave about an inch out of that got it
and then when I put fire and I knew I
was getting low I pop my lid open on my
can I had grabbed my thing of my sixty
round snap men and dump them in and
close it or the lid when it opened up
that ridges on the side it would slide
right in just dependent you know but
what was good about that box is you
could be blowing upside down or anything
you still have 130 rounds ready to shoot
you know I mean that's why we liked it
but that's place uh it was a it's a navy
experimental place called China Lake and
we saw we had them built in for us and
they work really well did you use a
sling yeah I don't know what we did is
we took the big buck plate off put an
aircraft but played on and if you
noticed in the back you have that round
thing that would take up who would cook
to see that bring it up and took a
hanger and made it down rule like this
and I put around the front of the hanger
so you could take it off when you
Chopra she can hold it down and then you
could take it off put it on but you got
it fit just right where it was just
right exactly where you wanted to do and
it worked great you know we were
invented fucks man we figured it out
anyone like we is on this one boat one
time and we saw these 60 guys they were
they had 60's on the boats you know they
had these big metal containers at the
round cylinder in the world what to
attend it was a flex tube that went into
the 60 and so a couple K bars later we
walked off with a couple of those and
they were fit perfect in the back of a
brick 77 backpack we can put them on
held 500 rounds and you had to flex dude
that went right into your 60 you had to
have a special feed Tory for you know
you know it's betrayed the the feet Roy
was right on the end of the flex tube so
it set right in there perfect so and
then if we're doing an off the chopper
charge the bunker up he had 500 rounds
right there it was kind of neat were the
only ones in Vietnam that at that fact
we came off choppers one time we're
doing parakeet ops I'll tell you about
that later and there was a whole bunch
army guides and stuff where we landed
with the choppers were getting out
beating each other on the back and a
couple good firefights and shit you know
and just and all the quarter light
coming up and everything we're all
bearded and you know Levi's and all that
shit and they're saying goddamn I told
you that mercenaries over here was a
Mercer than one guy says in all that
seals you guys had you guys are the
originators of the predator pack pretty
much I think I think we were they use
them on the boats but not on not out in
the field you couldn't the thought I'd
have to feed it
no it just it fed itself right how's the
botany data folder not out nothing it's
just group right through there but you
got to be careful because if you took
that thing off and laid it down and
didn't put a nail through the through
the Flex part of it all year round had
come out so they have this big pile 500
round that's not good you know
especially if used in a firefight and
stuff trying to put it back in you know
I'm just saying just funny but it was I
was pretty good me and our guy named to
us had those and we fixed them up just
just playing looking at I think
but you couldn't patrol at night with
them on patrol because it would
clank-clank he could hear a lot moving
that was only if you're actually going
off and hitting sub like you say there
are three types of ops we'd go into if
we hear we're going to take heavies one
was a downed pilot and another seal
platoon in trouble and a bright light
was by like that's a prisoner war going
in to hit them get them out but those
three ops or the main main three woody
wooden two no matter what it you know
yeah that's awesome you get so you
finish your work up and now you're over
till you go your first opponent of
Vietnam this kilo platoon yeah so Kela
platoon vietnam and you're saying you
were doing the first podcast you were
saying that he did dart board operations
which was have a guy huh cat dark
because you guys didn't have good intel
you didn't have good support okay we
were at a place called noon yam can and
it was a vietnamese a firebase out in bf
egypt you know and then we're here then
down here he had the river and sea full
where our other squad was but our squad
got put up here that was the one just
one squad out there by itself
yeah oh dang with the bid vietnamese
guys had a fire be sir okay and it was
not good intel so you basically would
throw a dart at the dartboard and then
do what go do an ambush there go set an
ambush may just go out and look set up
ambush or sup and see what was out
patrol yeah and that and you also were
inserting primarily on san-pan turn that
deployment pretty much as always we
about three times we walked out of the
fire base and locked back in that's just
that doesn't give you a warm and fuzzy
you know because change guards and stuff
and you come back in all a/c is moving
out there and maybe they don't know what
the bonafide he is for you coming back
in and shit and you don't say that so
yeah we didn't do a lot up at noon am
can because of that and we only had sand
pans we didn't have any of our boats up
there none of the mediums or lights or
anything so after we'd been up there for
about a month I think a month and a half
then they brought us maybe two months
and
then they brought us down the sea float
okay then we start doing some good
officer the sand pants how big is the
sampan how many guys could you fit in it
oh four or five so you take champion fam
because we were ever yellow today to
take you sand pants you could have you
ever gotten into a sampan no there it's
not a real stable bully Vietnamese are
good in them because they're small but
you get about five big Americans in
there and it's a you have to be real
careful and are you rowing it no I mean
it's got a little motor on the back and
a little like we use that again with
this we can put it along with us wasn't
it just ourselves now and then and then
someone would stay with the boats yeah
yeah the gozi and went or they believe
I'm going to come back and get us you
know but you didn't start working a lot
until you got to see flow yeah I mean
what kind of officer doing on a sea
float now same thing ambushes and going
upriver setting up ambushes and that's
when I told you I think you know I get a
little bit confused sometimes on PBRs
and Swift so I'm thinking they were PBRs
that were down the seafloor with but
they would we'd go up on the PBR and
have a Boston Whaler with us and a
Boston Whaler could probably hold four
or five guys you know plus the guy on
the front with a sixty and get the guy
driving well with the way we had worked
at is we had the whole platoon there one
platoon would be going to do something
well two guys out the other I mean other
one squatted go up and two guys from the
other squad luckily got to pick to be
the driver sitting up on a thing driving
the the Boston later and the other guy
in the 60s why everybody else was just
looking over the edge like this and
didn't get there again it wasn't you
didn't get real excited when you were
chosen to be the Coxon you know how
often would you guys make enemy contact
when you guys go out on ambush because I
had to be kind of like looking for a
needle in a haystack right yeah we got
some contact that was the one down at
square Bay I told you about when we hit
there when I wasn't on that when they
hit that junk and then all the mother
flavors are definitely
and a few other times we got in some
some crap that particular that that
platoon and that deployment wasn't we
didn't do an awful lot we went out a lot
get me wrong but we didn't get a lot of
firefights and stuff it was my second
book to that where we kicked ass today
and it sounds like I mean this is sort
of classic and you and I were talking
about this earlier today if you don't
have good Intel that said you know how
AM Bush all day without a sea float we
didn't have that good event Errol you
know like we didn't have a chief of a
platoon we had an LPO and no mention of
any names but he wasn't real good but we
had this other guy that Chief Coroner
told I'm not cheap at that Corman
it was the first class that he kind of
took over everything he had been with
the Marines twice ok Vietnam so he was a
good hand you don't need that I had a
shift together with smart and just a
couple funny things happen when it was
down the sea floor I told you where that
pile of clothes moved and such as head
of all you're looking for me we thought
we had lost him you know and that was
like this chopper comes in and lands to
him did one was pretty shot up and door
gunner had been hit so they said hey
anybody want to be a door gunner we got
to go back and pick up some other guys
well of course is a corpsman y'all go so
he's in unities he throws a flak jacket
on the Hillman and takes the door gunner
position and they take off and about a
half hour later the chopper comes back
in and lands shot up even more here he
gets off the I mean he gets off the boat
tows us helmet down takes it flat
shotgun fuck I'll never do that again
yeah those we had a this guy Colonel
Colonel reader on who was a pilot in
Vietnam he flew cobras in Vietnam the
second deployment but those guys those
pilots in Vietnam the helicopter pilot
in Vietnam they did not they knew they
were going to take rounds they just went
in anyways they were bad at that was the
same as our sea wolves and black
policeman Cecile's especially were just
unbelievable guys you know just uh they
were just badass dudes man they and I
told you at once or you and I bought
that one chopper
not all work so kind of pinned down
behind this rice dike and we're getting
some pretty heavy fire from the tree
lines so we're calling for close air
support that's the Seawolves you know so
we're getting up shooting getting back
down by 60 and we're getting kind of low
on ammo too except the sea walls
we always had a most aging on the sea
walls so he could kick it off to us when
they came in so the seagulls are coming
in we can hear the rotor wobble oh well
when the Seawolves weren't doing they
were the greatest when they weren't
doing a close air support that do psyops
they had these great big speakers and so
we hear this one sea wolf coming behind
us we're still shooting everything also
now the clear blue sky a sort of God you
hear this we are their gods or Hellfire
and we bring you fire and the fucking
Rockets one overhead hit the tree line
and they either had a fifty or a minigun
on one side of the sea wolf and that sea
wolf turn like that and just hold it
down I think that one had a minigun on
the right behind came another see well
but when they when we heard that we
really everybody just tops you two we
look back up like fuck oh it was unreal
and that scenario didn't really suppress
a fire so then the black bone they add
two point seven Rockets and black ponies
came in with the five in zoomies when
they hint hit the tree line it was
blowing shit clip overhead and that
pretty much quote still got out of this
sealord's came in the rigger Huey's that
picked us up and got us out of there
that was that was a good awful the the
sea Wolf's were the Navy pilots Navy
Vietnam Pyle townships that came in
supported we're like cobras they were
regular yeah they're regular that rocket
pods and I think kind of like the black
ponies had the 20 millimeter guns in the
front and then the five in Zooey's they
had the just a rocket pods but they had
a 50 on one side and or a minigun on the
other side and the most important thing
that they had from everything I've heard
and from what you're telling me right
now is they had balls oh yeah oh yeah
there was good they were just come in
and we got drunk one night
our bar and Seawolves are on the army
side that's where they had the thing so
we figured he'll look over and visit
them and have him drink with us so we
jumped in our six by and headed out we
were they had the army base here and the
Navy base here we lived on the
Vietnamese side and had her own home
barracks all fortified it was perfect
well anyway we got our six pine was
heading out went over where the sea wolf
guys where we want to drink with us you
know we had our 60s little stuff you
never knew you know so we get over there
and go walking in their compound
everything all right boys get up let's
drink well I'll see we made them drink
with us naked because we were all naked
so we're all sitting there drinking
beers
it makes nakedness em 60s and booze I
like where this is going yeah you guys
had way much the way more fun in Vietnam
oh yeah we are time I'm telling you we
weren't we would get back for not do or
debrief cleaner weapons and go up and
get shit-faced you know those thinker no
reader said the same thing he goes he
goes yeah you know we'd go out we'd fly
we get shot up we'd have to come back
and like put the birds in for repair I
didn't we'd get drunk yeah and then we
go he goes I don't know he really like
looked at me he said I don't know how
you guys did it without alcohol
basically yeah that was a you know went
to Desert Storm were over there nine
months and no alcohol sup it was okay
but it mean to me it was just like yeah
this isn't my war you know we really
didn't do that much in yeah you know the
guy did recons instead from my job and
we did that one deception up and when we
inserted the Quai tease each other
during in minutes outside that they
never really gotten to firefighter yet
you know yeah now that's that off with a
Seawolf that was I'm assuming that was
on your second appointment yeah that was
the first of your first appointment you
know you did what you did but it wasn't
as fruitful no I get to meet as the
honest-to-god truth coming out of 18 the
SEAL team I was ready to hit the deck
running and just being like we didn't
get the deck running over there
and just didn't have the Intel I don't
think are as you were saying leadership
was all that good and stuff I mean we
had one guy the LT what they were doing
some shit down in C folk but up where we
were we just didn't you couldn't it
wasn't that much you could do you would
go out and look try to find shit and
everything but we didn't have actual
Intel yeah that we could react on you
know what you found out later that's
what you have to have sometimes too I
think people spread their forces too
thin when you think about it you just
take a squad and put them out there in
the middle nowhere with no Intel support
and you got another squad in some other
area with no Intel support you know you
might as well bring them together put a
couple guys gather Intel and you start
making something happen the platoon
before us that was there and stuff that
that was the tune Mosley has gotten a
lot of shit you know hey that's when he
got a Medal of Honor and stuff like that
and actually my second trip over had
been in that platoon here on Amin and
Villa told me some stories about they
got a lot of shit but that's we were
stuck in Union can and just didn't well
shit like you can see the u-men force
which was at the very southern part of
Vietnam and it's just Triple Canopy just
I mean it's we were away from that a
little bit you know but this whole
Vietnamese guy there he had tattoos all
over and I guess he had fought with the
French against the Viet net Viet Minh
you know which was the bad guys fighting
the French the same as VC and and we're
tuned interpreter we're talking him and
I goddamn human force you know it's he
says yeah a whole company of French
Foreign Legion paratroopers jumped in
there and none of them ever came back
out and were gone plus that's what I was
telling you in my last podcast I did
that's where we landed and we're just
starting to put our shit away and just
loads lands and it's approved visor and
a good friend of mine real good friend
of mine now and then when that load took
off we got to ship mortared out for
about two hours and I absolutely told
him don't ever come here again
yeah so now when you get back you get
back you do another workup and well
actually got out for a little bit you
come back in you side you know that's
like when I went to college I had to go
I had to get my alt I got my commission
I had to go to college and people say
would you learn in college and I'd say I
learned in college never ever ever ever
get out of the teams everybody knows
what they do so you get out for a year
or something and you come back in and
get in your your second platoon getting
ready to go to Vietnam mber platoon yes
okay as he just passed and what a great
guy I mean I was he the platoon
commander yes he was the owner he died
we LT you know he's a great guy just a
great guy man yeah and he just passed
here about three weeks ago we went up
and Rosecrans and they buried him and
stuff but he was a great guy man and
that work up that work up did it did
must change between your first work up
until came in your second one actually
when I got out when we came back in I
went back to Kadri okay just a you know
kind of rush yourself refreshed had been
about a year as out you know I mean and
just what that's why he didn't keep one
if you were gone way over six months or
something you went back to Kadri yester
even the guys that came from these
coasts yes so they know how we worked
himself which was good while I was going
through Kadri Jerry Fletcher was out
there with us platoon and I got to know
him and I knew some of the other guys in
between so as soon as I got out of Kadri
they lost a guy in their platoon and
lucky enough I was good enough to get
into it so I didn't go through the whole
workup with November 2 I just got in it
and that's why I Stan you is down it to
greenfield they used to have a firing
range down there
and I was figuring out man might cute
sup Mel side you know that's when I
actually asked the first that's when I
picked up a sixty million this guy we
shot at this Korea so log pieces flew
off to Korea so log and we set it on
fire and I remember looking they look at
me it was like we're in exile that was
it
there are 62 beautiful things but no
it's a great thing so this next
deployment that you mentioned this on
the on the first podcast when you came
on about the orders that you got from
was it from Mac V SOG is that who you
can order scout nav for V nav for yeah
and we landed in Saigon and our Lt died
we went up to see where we're going to
go or what area we're going to work in
what province you know and he went up
there and they told him well you got the
VIN long province which is where dong
cam is and stuff and he said his orders
were to pacify it the hell was in and we
brought it he picked up a whole bunch of
money so we can pay our Kit Carson
Scouts enough like that we went to dong
town well we stopped had been luck first
it's about 40 miles away from dong town
there was another platoon there Gary
Gallagher's platoon and we shows up in
her six bodies and stuff and we're kind
of rugged looking because we'd been in
Saigon for three days and have a good
time and shitting comes walking out and
he looks at us he goes goddamn you guys
look like he'd been here six months
already you always a little bedraggled
to shit then we went to dong town but we
used to go back and forth God was an
applet ood George anger they just had
some great guys yeah and they were like
I said there were our system for tune
you know so we'd go and see each other
once in a while with the sister platoons
to play at the same time no they had
been over there for three months okay so
was it like a overlap of three months
the Antikythera and some of them yeah
the two of me go at the same time
usually when you got there there was
another platoon somewhere around yet
rather east coast or west coast course
East Coast had two platoons over there
so fun tell I'm thinking it was long
oh god I'm still trying to think of that
name it's right on a river and that's
where the East Coast platoon was we
never not be that's where was not being
and that's where the East Coast put
something out there they had the platoon
there and they had a platoon of metal
that was there two platoons and then we
took over when they left we took over
the one that dong Mito but we moved to
dog town because we didn't want to be
right in the middle of a city you know
or a big big yellow City though we moved
down to dong Tam and then the Navy base
didn't want us the army base didn't want
to so they put us in the Vietnamese base
that split them so there you go yeah
that was good we had our boats right
there everything was perfect we go to
the army base to test fire our weapons
is yet and they were doing that all the
time anyway so it wasn't it's another
thing I wonder how in retail how they
test fired their weapons in anyway so
what was your op temple-like when you
are on the second deployment was that
the deployment was a with God but every
two to three days cuz you had to gather
Intel and stuff like that and and it
would get a little break and if we were
real bored we'd do what we called
parakeet ops and there was this area I
don't know if I talked about this in the
first podcast but it was a place called
the plain of reeds and it was all enemy
as lvc and so we'd take off four or five
of us in a queue Ian have a Seawolf in
front and back of us and we just fly out
there start looking go over go over
small Hamlet's and villages and if you
see vc run around and get shot at they'd
land us with sweetu then they'd pick us
up we'd go look for some more you know
that's when we're bored you know we call
them parakeet offs
then the when we hit and start spreading
around the sea wolf would go off I mean
not see what the Sealord which is our
Huey and then the Seawolves and start
circling looking first quarters and
stuff you know it was good
we might get in two or three firefights
you know yeah I guess yeah
that's not that was daytime off you yes
you're just running those daytime office
and what you will you just look at the
map and say hey this is probably no oh
yeah the planner reads the whole place
a leaky stronghold VC stronghold a lot
of VC out there so and then that's when
we took a couple of the Austrians with
us on that those parakeet outs and stuff
in the boom out of the water how they
like it did they come back for more oh
yeah we other groups come down less than
I mean that from do we debt worthy
Australian SAS word went out with him
and that was pretty pretty unique yeah
my sexy and about 500 rounds 120 pound
pack and walked around for about eight
days I was real happy about that yeah
that's no joke it was good they were
they're great troops and you know they
loved coming down working with us
because we got contact and when they you
know they're they look for things to see
if what they could find they had two
types that you had a five man fighting
patrol or attend I mean a five man Ricky
or a ten man fighting patrol where we
went out with him it was a ten man
fighting patrol because we were going to
go into this area that the Australian
armored infantry had taken over this
North Ian in the North Vietnamese army
base camp and just decimated it well our
job was to go see if any the NVA able
back into the area or not it was good
that's like I said my first podcast is
the best reconnaissance guys I've ever
ever worked good so they're fighters -
yeah they're good good good good troops
yeah a lot of some reason a lot of
people ask me if you've ever worked with
foreign troops everyone want to come
kind of wants to know what we think of
their countries and their troops you
know and you know the Brits and the
Aussies you know the SAS or top Jill for
sure none of the only ones that went out
with us on patrol and I think were in
Vietnam we were the only ones that one
out of them you know you know it all
started out with a couple of SAS guys
drinking the bar with a couple our guys
and Cooper Pat's and telling tall tales
and you know drinking beers and shed
next thing you know we have this
exchange and it's been ongoing sense
yeah always when I was a team one there
was always out on SAS guy there yeah
Julia did you when you went to good did
you get to go to off so I never went
though oh you'd love it
that's embarrassing shit it's great I
always got a always got screwed out of
going on I went for five times after
Vietnam and Hill there was still guys
there that had been to Vietnam with yes
you don't mean it was good it was great
yeah I I always got screwed for some
reason I'd always go well yeah yeah
we're going to Australia tell me
something will come up when we wouldn't
get to go that's because your platoon
officer wasn't very well liked or
something hey most likely what uh when
you say you get contact a lot so you're
doing an OP every two three days how
often are you guys getting an enemy
contact just about every time we went
out because we were going out on
actionable Intel I don't mean and uh I
said I can't think of all of it like
that one time I was telling you in
another time we hit these two hoochies
and guys came out it was like the OK
Corral except we won and another time
we're doing this recon just looking and
that's one guy forgets up on top of this
bunker because we couldn't find any
entrance around it they may have had a
tunnel come into it some learn he's up
there I'm staying here in this guy so as
a six he's there and we're kind of
watching the area for him while he's up
there looking around and cue to into
tune right by me comes as 1847 rounds
and they missed me I don't know how the
hell they missed me but then jumps off
the the bunker down right beside me was
gone yeah the guys over there the guys
over there and we hear yelling and we'll
shoot the son of a bitch finally we saw
where his rounds came in and we start to
another time we got pinned down a little
bit and we were going to go and hit this
check this hospital out and stuff when
we got hit pretty hard we had to pull
back and now move out that might have
been when we got pinned down you know
was that when you called him to
Seawolves yeah we called them in a few
times you know ya know it's interesting
because people think that every time you
go out you're going to get enemy contact
and you could see I mean your first
deployment it was rare that you'd get
enemy contact the second time it's a lot
more often yeah like my first deployment
to Iraq we got like a like four or five
firefights maybe and they were all
pretty like not really a big deal
and then when I was a troop commander an
ahmadi the platoons were getting into it
although almost every not almost
everybody a lot of times I mean a
majority of times there'd be there be
shooting going on you know yeah I might
tell you have talked to a lot of guys
that were in your platoon in Ramadi and
they did follow you to that the hell if
they had or they loved him so just
letting you know you had a real good
impression and you you were outstanding
just telling you if that's for my guy
and you know talk to the guys on the
ground drinking and stuff when your name
comes up yeah well they're drunk I guess
that's that the Reno I'm just telling
you it's like you know you know well
those guys were those guys did those
guys actually never mind they would they
did they did all kinds of stuff that was
above way above and beyond the call of
duty for sure and got the light you took
it to him and that's what that's what
you're supposed to do you know yeah it
was a the awesome point of awesome
deployment with working with awesome
guys for sure hell we went out one time
and we heard there was this cachet you
know so but we did want people to know
they were going out there so we got into
a refrigerator truck and getting it back
to that until they got close to where
the cachet was and we went out and dug
it up and came back just little things
you know right it was a neat up yeah
that's uh that it's good stuff when um
when you get back from that deployment
and that was the last November when was
the last fully deployed to Vietnam yeah
and you didn't get me you can go back to
sue back when you were sealed in did you
know that was like no gate there the
whole time yeah well you did get two
weeks or a week or two weeks I think of
R&R and uh I think I went to Hawaii and
Thailand 1 times X supports your choice
of going to Hawaii from Hawaii so yeah
Hawaii ously bad know kind of where
don't go into Hawaii and everything is
all quiet and peaceful and everything
and you just come out of the woods and
you know after you've been there for a
while you you you kind of want to go
back you know
I don't know if Ida went to Thailand I
probably would have stayed in Thailand
still in there now not probably be dead
just a lot of people that you go to
Thailand and don't come back bangkok
makes the hard man humble here until you
do the I remember the last time we
talked about this blue-on-blue that you
guys had was that in November pool - no
that was in kilo oh that was in kilo
play and that was our no Azhar the
officer that was within union candy and
it was like to say it was supposed to be
a hammer and anvil up it just went wrong
yeah and I I'm not sure if he was a
stood up to shoot or if he was trying to
wave and tell him her adoption anyway he
got hit you know killed him so and then
we almost had another in November
platoon I forgot to mention this so
we're hitting this island it's not a big
island but it had hooches all along one
side so they wanted us to go through
check out the huges and we had what we
called white mice with us they were
Vietnamese Intel guys that could look
through things and find out if there's
any VC stuff you don't mean something so
we lands and were sweeping through it
and I had this one white Mike's with me
and I had my 60 well the guy that
planned this off and thought it was a
good idea was our dead golf guy and deck
golf was your senior SEAL was at deaf
golf and he was kind of in charge of all
the other platoons that were spread out
and so we did it and he was with us and
his interpreter so and we were told
everybody stay on the side when we
Patrol because anything on the left side
is a free-fire zone is right so we're
walking along and I'm looking at the
woods also I see this flipping through
the woods so I bring my 60 up take it
off a safe and I'm watching well where
the woods were there was a space and
another part of woods where I wanted the
VC who I thought it was to get out in
the space and then a hammer you know
open up with my 60 and we were spread
out a little bit because everybody was
checking different things out as we're
going along so I had it off safe I'm
just having laid it up on this uh
rice rice bag you know with rice on
just waiting who comes out but the
typical commander the head golf guy I
was so fucking pissed
I'd have been a new guy I'd open up you
know me maybe killed him and think so I
told Jerry Fletcher my auntie about it
and he never went out with us again
because that was crazy he was on the
three fires old you don't mean and like
you say what if I'd been a brand-new guy
or something but I wanted to wait till
it got out so I had a clearer picture
before I opened up on him yeah I mean
even your mindset wasn't even let me
confirm this is a bad guy you knew it
was a bad guy you're just waiting for
the Hangout the bad guy no lutely I
wasn't saying hey that might be one of
our guys it was a bad guy because we had
already briefed heavily everybody stay
on this side anybody over there and you
see him open up on him you know when I
was running training man I I worked
those guys they wear that blue and blues
all the time in training I mean we would
just make stuff so confusing and just
put the enemy in the wrong place and get
guys confused I wanted them to have blue
on blues and training so they realized
how easy it is to happen so you get a
guy instead of making that decision like
all just you know what this part get a
good vantage point over here if I just
walk over here and they'll know it's me
you know it's like no they won't know
it's you they'll kill you so yeah it's
uh you got a people to understand how
confusing it gets out there man it gets
confusing does that's that's all your
training you're like I was telling you
though it saved our butt Vietnam lazar
immediate action girls and have them so
ingrained into us that it's dark you
know exactly where the guy is going to
be and what you're going to do whether
it's a peel off or whether you're going
to the right or left you know I mean ya
get now the the fire zone whatever you
know I mean yeah but you had to have
them and as immediate action drills to
me or the key no matter what you do
another turbine or I think which I can't
really say no it's the same thing it's
the same thing at an urban environment
you got to have a media I just like to
say you have a hoots there and you're
going to get the hoots you know we know
there's probably bad guys in it and
we're coming in what we do is two guys
to branch out to the right or left to
get anybody from behind the wrestler
would go in one guy would turn around
look that way the guys that go in and
that way they could shoot you know
one atw don't mean nobody was down now
so hooch was covered and had foliage
around it then as we came in one of the
guys on the left or go down lay down
look behind the other guy be right here
at the corner so he could see anybody
coming out of window and then we'd have
the other guy over here and then we'd go
in and hit it but what I'm saying is
when we did that it was like that I mean
that and that was our immediate action
stuff that we did that's how we'd hit a
hooch yeah and then when guys went in
that switch one swing high one or two
along just a you know to check it out
then they'd guilty then they'd say clear
or we got someone and then whoever was
right next to the door facing out
because we had her security and didn't
know if anything but he was going to
come behind you as they bring the guy
out like I had my 60 I'd stick my 60
right between his legs and it fall down
then I put my safety in his mouth and go
he wouldn't say much you know it would
take off that you were talking about how
the SAS one time you went off show the
SAS and they went out do you out there
for like 10 days and no one said a
single word not a local time if you did
say seven you put here right next to the
guys or your mouth yeah right next to
the zero and talked but normally it was
all hand signals but like what you're
talking about all the stuff that you
just described to do all that stuff
without thought everybody knows where to
go it's om it's a standard operating
procedure it's the immediate action
drill and everybody knows exactly what
to do and yeah that's just like you get
a booby trap or something the smartest
thing to do is back away and come in a
different way but if you had to keep
going you'd feel it with your hand and
grab the guy next year behind you and
show him where it was then you'd step
over it move on a few steps wait till he
got over by grabbing the guy behind him
and you just keep how often would you
guys do that not too often we did one
too occasionally but we were kind of
lucky we never hit Plus you'd see a tree
you'd be able to pick up the signs if
you did happen to go on a trail you can
see broken branches faced in a certain
way or little little sticks point in a
certain way or or actually we got landed
one time in this rice paddy and we
looked after we got off everybody
started
and all you can see was - dorri signs
which a man minefield so we didn't move
you know we just call the stoppers back
in took us so your your second
deployment to Vietnam how many Castle
how many caps did no one got killed I
know we didn't get anybody hit or killed
no one got hit or killed despite getting
all those gunfights don't ask me which
is one of those things god the frogman
yeah we figured you know we're getting
to the point that's why we had six-month
deployments and not a year or you know
whatever because you start getting
feeling like you're invulnerable you
know but how do we were on the cutting
edge and uh we just add the firepower
we're better I mean you could add the
outs out like that one yeah one that
went right by me or something I could
have hit me right in the chest no you
had too much skill to get hey Joe I got
ya what skill that you're lucky I know
it's like unfortunately in combat you
can do everything right you can still
get killed and get all kinds of things
wrong and live we did that stay behind
ambush that one night I think I told you
about that I don't think so okay so but
our second op we hadn't Vietnam thought
hmm we're going to go and hit this one
area here and if nobody's in the little
village or anything like that then we're
going to do a stay behind ambush and so
a squad of us went in and patrolled
through through some Willie Peter into
hooches and shit like that just kind of
caused hate and discontent and then the
Sun started going down so soon as it
started going down we got in an l-shaped
ambush being where rice bags are going
this way that way and stuff and then we
had the other choppers came in like they
were going to pick us up we had other
squad on it they got off the chopper ran
around and got back in it like we're
being extracted right so we sat there
and sat there for about 45 minutes
almost an hour
Nelson's you know these guys come
walking down this rice dock with ak-47s
and shit and stuff and we opened up on
him and you know blew him off the rice
Dyke and hidden and then they opened up
on us from the treeline hit him a little
bit the Seawolves came in did some
damage and shit and then
the fucking chopper teams in there's
only one of them so we all couldn't get
on it we landed with two choppers you
know so me and another guy radio woman
and a STONER guy myself
stayed there why that chopper went on
cam wasn't too far away come back and
picked us up you know my poop was a
little tighter tight on that that's a
how long about how long were you sit on
the ground
Oh about another 20 minutes to that
loneliness but nobody came into the
village after that because we'd with
hammered him you know pretty that so
that was pretty good that was it bring
it up anyway so I'm shooting my 60 he's
over here shoot in 40 mike-mike in
there's a small stream between us and we
got back for drinking beers Pat and
Cooper's Dean you know tell them tall
tales and she has it says goddamn didn't
you see that fucking string around so
went right by you on the stream and I
says no because I shoot my 60 in the
book it was pretty the you know I mean
that's a good times over there now
that's that's an amazing deployment to
do well that was a behind ambush classic
yeah I mean just the way you want to do
it they knew we were there they thought
we had left they came in and we got two
summer bitches no and then they always
say you know did you shoot a guy
yourself well you know when you open up
with stoners and sixties you see guys
flying off a rice taxes yet you're not
sure if it's or 60 that hit em or if
it's a STONER or whatever you know so
it's only one time I know I hit a guy
for a fact is that often that when we
came off the choppers and did that old
cake or L think oh yeah well then me and
a guy another guy went around the before
the squad continued moving by we want to
check out the back you know so he and I
goes walk around and he had a car he was
our corpsman and I saw him walk around
the edge and fire about three times I
stepped by he missed the guy and here's
this guy with an ak-47 right about here
and I stepped around with my 60 pointing
right at it you know and I just flipped
him yeah I think we joined up and went
kept going and then three guys popped up
out of the rice dike and one they
started shooting at us we were shooting
back but a Seawolf was coming right over
us and three rounds went right to the
instrument panel
Seawolf didn't hit anybody they turn
like this my guy had a minigun and just
went oh and we just dropped down because
there was fucking rounds going
everywhere yeah that's that the amount
of firefights you guys are getting to
take no Cassity yeah we're getting that
amazing you know that's amazing and we
didn't have a lot of pictures either
because we didn't have a professional
photographer walking around with it yeah
I mean it's a we missed I would say in
Ramadi we missed the real like a couple
deployments later maybe a year later
when guys were going on deployments they
had pictures everything because they had
helmet cams they had all this stuff and
we did it as a matter of fact at that
time there was like rules against taking
pictures so we don't have a bunch of
picture we did we never had both
platoons I was in we took one just
before we deployed you know the whole
platoon and then hardly nothing else
after that we wouldn't let photographers
close to us who wouldn't let news people
even come closer on Vietnamese basically
where they couldn't get on it it was
perfect and we just yeah we just when
I'm did everything and I had a good
diamond didn't beat no drums about it
you know what I mean it was it was good
there's a couple book teams that had a
photographer with him that took a lot of
pictures and she had a new probably
you've probably seen them stuff and you
know we didn't yeah and they're still
tuned as well for in Iraq there was
platoons that gotten from that's one of
the reasons why we didn't take pictures
because there was platoons that had
pictures that got exposed and got
released and they wouldn't if there were
pictures they should have taken and they
got trouble and it but you know not just
that they got in trouble but it was bad
press bad press for America you know and
that's why there was rules is like hey
no picture so we don't have a lot of
pictures of women we can do a hundred
things right and you do one thing wrong
and that's what's going to pop up yeah
and you do one thing wrong and you take
a picture of it and that's in these days
you know that pictures going around the
world and all in 30 seconds yeah so it's
a the debts one thing that has
definitely changed and like I said when
we were in Ramadi we were just on the
like I don't think people were really on
social media yet that we
everybody had a camera and not everybody
you know had a video cam these guys got
video cameras now they got helmet cars
they got all the stuff and you know some
of its good some of its beneficial I
mean you're not going to get any better
Intel there was a company commander from
the first of 506 who was one of the best
guys I've ever worked with but he
videotaped every time he went out on
patrol in a Humvee or or not in Humvee
however he was on patrol he filmed the
whole thing and he was working in one
specific district of Ramadi called the
moola district and he would come back
and watch those videos and he would just
he and I sat there Watson with him one
time and he was yeah you see this
garbage can over here yeah this this
one's a good landmark because it's a
different color and then up on this
street corner right here is a this this
pole is always filled with so many wires
it always scares me you know because
there's so many wires hanging off and he
just had the whole city memorized
because he had a camera rolling in his
Humvee the whole time and for so for
that reason plus when you gather Intel
you know you're going into a building
and and you got pictures of everything
you got if anyone ever goes in that
building again you hear - here you go
here's one it's laid out so there's some
definite benefits to it but yeah there's
some real drawbacks as well if you know
four people can use that stuff for
propaganda against you or if you're
videotaping things or you're recording
things that are going to make you know
the Americans look bad and now you're
saying okay you did this well here's
what was happening in the situation
here's why this happened and here's the
context well the contact isn't going to
make it onto YouTube the only thing
that's going to make it onto YouTube is
the thing that makes America love that
and that's what's going to so that's
getting that's what the reporters are
going to kion we got ready yep see we
had barn dance files I tell you about
that he did mention them yeah barn dance
files were this every time you went on
an OP and you came back the guy was
telling was her Intel guy or first class
and we'd fill out these barn dance cards
why they call them barn dances I got
just the prom' word for whatever word
but if they had to who where what wise
equipment anything we found out there
what fire fights who got into what I
don't know what the enemy were using
anything that would be good Intel and
it's just a 5 by 4 by 5 card but it was
really good in every platoon like our de
platino we relieved
already
had their so if we're going back into a
specific area that that went into we had
it organized y'all would look it up
caught up read and see what they hit and
what they got and all that stuff and
that would be help us out when we were
going on with winter we did a briefs and
stuff and we do the same thing but every
platoon would have these barn dance
files of what they did and the areas
they went into and stuff and it was
pretty good you know that's how we did
it you know that we didn't do the camera
quarter like they're saying but we
anything that we saw that would be of
interest of another patrol or another
platoon going into that area then we'd
let them know you know these abundance
files yeah and then like I said when we
got to Don Tam then long province what
did have split us up into provinces or
districts in that province and then we
would go out whether Kit Carson Skeletor
interpreter and gather Intel from the
PSP guys the Chiefs are from the SF that
were out in the field and or Rangers
that were doing fire bases and stuff
like that and bring that back and then
we would put it up on our set map and
start working you know like we had this
one we knew through our our province
that this one
BCI which is your high level guy they
wouldn't transmit communication wise
they would bring your orders in and
packets you know I'm saying and he would
come through the province maybe once a
month
we're on several all the different
information yeah he was handed as of the
VC what they want to get the stuff but
he had all this stuff we knew he came
through there every time but there were
three different trails that he used
because we've gotten Intel we didn't
know which one it was you know so we
went out on the one trail did an ambush
whack some people and shit like that so
we knew who next time he came he wasn't
going to do that trail and then we did
the same thing on the other trail right
so we figured he's going to come down
this trail so we set up on him got him
he came down that trail and we got him
got some good Intel that's beautiful but
that was just working with actionable
Intel kind
figure it out and work in it you know so
worked out real good we you on that I've
always heard about this OP where they
wanted to get this one VCI and they
ended up hitting like his his family or
some member of his family and then when
they went to their feet when they had
the funeral they went got the guy but
you know I wasn't on that and there's a
lot of things that happened and like you
say when you're in your platoon that's
kind of your world not something I've
heard I don't remember hearing about
that but I probably was one time in the
Tradewinds the bar we used to drink at
Coronado were so I'm sure that that was
brought up like I used to hit tax
collectors and get their Pyaasa from
their money and then they would turn
turn that into MPC and stuff you know
just different things yeah guys we're
going to have a nice collector because
that's that's a good thing you know I'm
I supporting and it clarity and if you
had a whole bag full of money well oh
well you know I know that's that's
awesome that's and it's all another
thing that people you know it's all self
generated so much of it is self
generated like when you're talking about
the same thing for us I mean I had an
Intel group but my Intel group was seals
some Intel seals and some Intel guys and
they created all of our Intel and you
know our guys fed into it and so we
produced our own targets kind of like
what you're saying yeah
people have this thought that you know
that the assault force is sitting there
waiting for some command to come down
and go hit this target but if the
reality is we're making up the targets
were figured about ourselves most of the
time yeah well I can see the difference
from my first platoon or we didn't have
anything
and my second platoon where we actually
worked off of actually actionable Intel
that we got it was like night and day I
would do it's a whole different world
and just like we talked about before we
started this you know you got your fine
you got your fix and then you got your
finish and exploitation of you don't
mean death but that were the best world
I think on DEA stuff to finish but you
can't do the finish if you don't have
the fine where you know what to go and
hit you know to me and that's why a long
time ago we started up that field craft
the stuff that we are pro advisors we
had a trained side up in queen maca you
know we called to advanced training and
it was for our food advisors because
they would go over there by themselves
or with one other American and have
about 50 VC whatever that they were in
charge of and that proves actually were
for when the CIA would could collect
Intel but they didn't have a method of
going out and hit that you know react on
doing the finished part of it so that's
when they started the proof program we
had her what preventional Prevention
recon units that is what they were
called proves we compost like to say if
I throw out an accurately I know I'm
just ladies I'm just so used you know
anyway and they would pull select guys
to go through this poo training and East
Coast guys to and then they would go
over and work for any said they be in
charge
you said VC but you didn't mean that Rex
vc x VZ I'm not the active guys that you
toys and stuff and decide they want to
make money here I mean so more centers
is what they were and so they had that
training are you hoiding trade does it
mean turncoat what is it to hoist a guy
that yeah you left the the ulema died or
the MBA and went to three shelves in no
Asahi holy actually mean no I don't the
actual noun of it yeah except but it was
they had put him in this camp and like
when we went to dong Tim we went to that
camp with our interpreter but we just
happen to have a special boat guy at the
time MST we called a mobile support team
not SBU that spoke fluent Vietnamese so
we'd bring him with us when our
interpreter didn't realize this guy
could speak Vietnamese to and then we'd
start interrogating guys for our
district that we're in you know for
myself or them long where the guys were
and we would talk to him and Tara gate
him and stuff and they sounded like they
were good to go then we'd bring him in
and scare Carson Scouts and they would
stay with us we'd let him go and stuff
but anytime we had an off they stayed
with us until the OP was done and stuff
you know I mean they we just didn't let
them go they turned out that they
were great guys and anyway the proof
program was about six months long and
half of was to a grasshopper was medical
because you had to have that when you're
working out there the medical especially
because you're on your own out there you
know you got a bill to take care of
yourself as he hit and then they would
come over but these guys were also after
they got done like for going to another
platoon it would be able to get that is
everything he did but we had about seven
guys at or six guys he was one of them
that went to a special school like Camp
Perry but it wasn't camp air as
different as a shorter version and they
got that training and they're the ones
that were the Kadri for that set and
like my loud first Platoon in 69 my
whole platoon went through most of that
before we deployed over so you get all
that stuff we didn't get the field craft
portion of it but they had some great
really good quick kill trails and stuff
like that and map and compass and
everything you know me yeah and we're
lucky because the platoon every once
whilst they didn't have guys going see
would be able to pick that up and go
through it but that was superb training
I mean really good yeah that's yeah it
all boils back to training all the
business yeah that's one of that's one
of the best things about the SEAL Teams
is that they called it to advanced
training looks at training and
specifically before the provincial recon
units that they sent the guys over to so
when you got back from that deployment
of Vietnam now like I said that was
November plane was the last full
deployment through Vietnam and you now
you know the war is kind of over but but
you stayed in the teams did you go right
to buds I mean yeah after that so I get
these orders to the amphibious based I
thought what's the ship yeah because
that's when the dirty thirty was happy
no that's oh yeah I didn't realize it
actually in the thirty thirty two people
dirty thirty is where after the war we
had too many people and they wanted to
cut us down
so even though guy just got on a train
stuff they picked three guys to go out
to the fleet be divers eld and stuff
like that and after two years
you come back or whatever and it was
just sucked it was just went into one of
the low points I think of the team's
imagine just major made it to buds and
or UDT training whatever they call her
back then I might have been buds and
next thing you know you're you know
you're going to dive school or somewhere
soon I went over to and that was really
pissed I went over to two buds as an
instructor land warfare was a third
phase and all that shit but they still
had LD an end program going on then
which is our
you know gotten his action some other
guys didn't I want to stay there and
still do the Eldeen ends but I I think I
don't know I just was one selected go to
bud and when I got done with buds I went
back at team one how long were you a
buzz instructor for in just those two
years yeah yeah and then you go back to
t1 I was there again for about seven
years and took about three or four
platoons you know I mean yeah when you
see buds now because you still are in
the community is there any major
difference that you notice between what
you went through and what you see now a
lot more land warfare now yeah I think
the kids get trained better there's so
much more to learn yeah I don't know
half our class Paulie would have flunked
his academically with what the guys got
to know now I swear to God
what a frogman it was you know wasn't
that hard but now with all the calm and
everything those guys go they teach in
that lesson buds they teach common buds
they teach some of it yeah not all of it
some of it may a lot of ID's when I go
out to San cominius if I guess they do
maybe they don't maybe that's more and
sqt but yeah they got to use radios out
there in buds but it's just a it's a
mixture between what we did in xqt and
what was the frogman but I think the
frogman part of it the UDT part of it is
kind of really slacked off I think they
do a few cursory parallel perpendicular
recons and stuff like that but when I
went through we were no fucking water so
much it was so cold
nobody always says you let this you
earned your wet seat and it wasn't a
full wetsuit it was just the well that's
for sure that was the same with me we
had we had the old wetsuits with beaver
tails and we even when I went through
this is 1991 right and so it's not like
you couldn't get a season good surfing
wetsuit because I surfed and I knew what
a good sweat suit was so they give me
that shitty uh
wetsuit with the beaver tail which is
exhibiting a big loose open it looked
like a 1970s disco there's so much water
going through that thing it was almost
not worth well we we our first swim was
the UD keys to no fins or nothin you
your friends go yeah when you got reishi
ation yeah they had a day they called it
wet through depreciation and then it hit
Lauren she's also to get your fins too
you know and then we got our fans that
we still give a couple swims without the
wetsuit that we got our wet suit I mean
it was like Jesus Christ yeah everybody
always says yeah you don't mind cold
water D and I says I've hated cold water
all my life it's just part of her job
and it's what you do you know I'm saying
yeah you only get wet once yeah that's
what I like you know what you just oh
you're gonna get wet you can't wet one
time and it doesn't matter anymore yeah
but the I mean there's certain things
that I don't think you've changed like
there's always been a 5.5 nautical mile
swim yeah right that I don't think
that's gotten any shorter I forget that
just is what it is a lot of the
standards of state descend physically
yeah and it fluctuates a little bit I
think about who's the director over buds
and mmm how many times they roll people
back and then thing back in the day I
mean if a guy was God dropped or
something he was gone I never saw him
again
he was just he's out there you know it
wasn't come back later but maybe they
did after a couple years like we had a
guy in our class named getting hit in
been in class 37 I think and he had
broke his hip and then he was in my
class and he made it you know I mean
really got hypothermia bad good man no
there was a guy there's a guy in my
class that had rolled back is Jeff Higgs
as a matter of fact he's a jujitsu guy
but he had - they dropped him for
hypothermia and he would and he wouldn't
so they told him he's out there like
you're done hey man listen you're a
great guy but you can't you can't be in
the program anymore
because you just get hypothermia too
easy and he's like no I'm not leaving
and they gave him his dungarees back
which is like the regular mavey thing
that you wear yeah and he showed up with
the class on Monday with his dungarees
on just pee teen with the class in the
compound and they looked at him in there
like I will give this bastard another
shot
yeah he was a he's a hard dude he made
it through but you know hypothermia like
heated heated exhaustion when you get it
there the heat thing yeah that'll come
back and bite him you know it really
does I mean I swear to God hypothermia
is like that - yeah if you get a real
bad guy sciatica I knew it was like that
with heat exhaustion but I know I was
like that with hypothermic it is I mean
maybe I'm wrong yeah I'm just that's
where I've heard so I don't know well
I'm lucky because I've always been
pretty well marbled in terms of
insulation there's those really skinny
lean dudes I live on doubt if you swim
as hard as you can you usually stay warm
and that's a good boy I don't like
treading water in cold water
you know like that swimmer line I was
telling you about that was that was
painful God Almighty that was cold and I
told you when we first got to buds they
had us go down to 401 and gave us a talk
you know a guy left hidden right here
won't be there it's easier to pass a
marshmallow through the keyhole of a
needle and make it through and roll
going yeah whatever
and so they marked us all back in front
of the bay you know I told you around
the Bayside you know the guy's telling
about come walking out any kind of like
a square kind of like yeah yeah how
tough can this be and everything and he
said about faith
forward march and marked us all other
dress blues right in the water so you
got your flap stick out like this all
the white hats loading and the officers
hadn't kind of looked at each other when
goddamn this may not be that easy and
went downhill from there you know that's
definitely ruining our dress blues dude
yeah that sucks that's difficult so you
got done you got done with being buds
instructor you went back and you did a
bunch but how many platoons did you do
thank again overall nine that's not that
many but I mean it was good actually
that is a lot for anyone that's less
than doing nine pavilions a lot because
that's nine platoons with work ups yeah
that's like 20 years worth of work right
there and then you know I had a story
about you and you got into a fight with
some guy at Nylund oh yeah
ya know it was like you got to fight
with some guy and I don't know that one
that was this guy that was just out of
presents the one yeah blue-eyed Aryan
about six six yeah yeah somehow you know
I heard the story from my platoon chief
Annie and he said realities that Roger
aids the toughest bastard alive and I
singles yeah one time we're out at
Nylund and there's some guy in a bar and
he whatever something happens and you
guys throw down and apparently you guys
had like a legit like five maybe ten
minutes fight oh it was terrible yeah so
I walked in the bar and I'm just sitting
there and they song kept playing that's
what certain she rides us a little
better or not funnier you ask the
bartender god damn can you play a
different song guy turns it off and this
great big guy stands up like this idiot
blonde hair about six four I think let's
just look you know steel blue eyes and
stuff and how come you turn that off and
a bartender pointed right to me well he
said turn it off and then the guy looks
at me and I went I don't want to fight
you know that's just you just don't get
in fights them so I started walking out
the door going across the other bar
which is right across the street like
you wouldn't have followed me so he
follows me out the door and I turned and
looked at him I said now he's going to
follow me over there were probably won
at fighting so I jumped on one foot
twice and hit him as hard as I could and
then right in the jaw knock him down his
head went like this and and hit the wall
and sumbitch stood right back up and I
went holy shit you know what we did
about a ten minute fighting he actually
never hit me one time because I just I
wasn't really good shaping out an island
yeah running and you don't mean and so
finally we squares off again you know
and I look at him he looks at me and
yeah I'm covered blood but it's his
blood dripping on me because I just kept
your punch if the guy ever hit me here
to kill me he was fighting for fun I was
fighting for my life
that's a deal so he scores off again and
finally I went Wheaton I'm not tired yet
and we can keep on fighting or we can go
across the street to have a beer
he thought about it he says well let's
go have a beer puts his arm around me
you're pretty tough for a little guy but
I mom was quiet I gotta thank God as
father tells us like I've ever been Ian
that guy was a Jesus and then I found
out he'd been in prison yes and that's
what he did his weightlifting boxer
loose in prison ya know how I got out of
that I'll never know because a punch
line was that dude just got out of
prison it was a weightlifter in a box
with Scott boxer yeah I was uh I was a I
was that worn out a few moments of
excitement in that one and then you uh
you became a Warrant Officer yeah I was
a master chief I was master chief of
group one and that that was all I was
going to do I thought I wasn't going to
go walk home or anything and that's when
they came out with a warrant program so
I put in for a warrant and went warrants
and then deployed to Desert Storm came
back and then we started the that
special program I was in that did that
for about a year year and a half and a
benevolence of war con decided we didn't
need that anymore so they took us all
and put us in to run the first sqt
for group one instead of having that two
teams and then we did that and then I
went from that to start doing orys it's
awesome all finished after Laurie put
when I was in my second platoon all the
guys to all of our new guys went through
your your s QTL and we've been going for
like two hours right now just um I want
to get one more question some some
people listen to the podcast that want
to go into SEAL Teams and you know any
sort of thought on what they should be
thinking about when they're trying to
get in or trying to go fast me all the
time you know I always say real simple
stuff you know like hey do a bunch of
pull-ups push-ups dips swim run and
don't quit and and that's how you make
it into the SEAL Teams that when you get
in the SEAL Teams you know work your ass
off well you know you get all those kids
up at the pre-training Upper Great Lakes
you know physically fit perfect and it's
the mental thing it's you got to take
each day at a time when you get there
and if you fin
sad day be real happy and get the next
day and keep going on going to look
ahead of what you got to do but it's
like when I was a second time as the bus
struck as a massive arms you know not
get all these guys in and I'd tell them
if you want to do everything we want to
do and have the easy life go Leo D if
you think you're going to be a diver and
working diver
I said go be a diver I told him if you
want to be cold wet and miserable then
go on the seals but I will say one thing
even going through buds and you can
probably attest to this that just gets
you into the teams and then you deploy
and that's where you pull from what you
experienced some buds rather where you
have to push yourself to the end you
know like there again to in 69 we were
doing this when I was with kiloton who
were going to set up this ambush on this
river we had to go through about a click
and a half of mangrove shit network was
all grey and shipped from Agent Orange
and shit I was up to my knees in mud up
to my waist and water and when you're
holding your weapon up high enough to
keep it out of the water and you go for
about a click and a half in that shit
using just compass because then we
didn't have GPS and all that shit and
you kept going to your rent into the
stream or whatever you're going to set
it up on you had a strain headache so
bad your fucking eyes were crossed and
your breathing and mosquitos in your
mouth and spitting them out and shit
like that that's a now you do that and
you come back three beers and Pat
poopers you know you're good to go
or you're in Korean and pull hang and
you got to hit the target but you got to
go over about three mountain ridges
because you can't run the ridges and
create got to go up and down them and
come out of a submarine and land on the
beach and it's cold and you're you're
kind of covering why one guys trying to
take up a sweat suit and he's falling
down until he gets the opposite then you
do it and you get about halfway up the
first mountain ridge before you start
getting warm
that's when you find out if you if you
got it or not the bottom line is we
complete the mission you know yeah
that's what we do no matter what but
like I say buds shall we call that shit
just get you your mind in the right
place to know that well goddamn I went
through hell week I can give you this
you know what I mean and other things
like the five mile swim and all that
stuff and that's all no it's just that
it's it's more you I've seen when I was
an instructor great big guys that were
football players fall out and quit and
I've seen little skinny guys that you
laugh at thinking this guy's going to be
a seal and he makes it through
so because of up here is mine you know
do you agree I mean is that yeah and and
I've always you know the blood to the
screening process and you don't actually
learn much in buds it just gets rid of
the people that don't want to be there
and the real test comes when you know
when you get into combat because going
into you know being cold wet miserable
for two or three or four or five days
and training and do a bunch of push-ups
doesn't compare to what you were just
talking about arguing yeah I figure the
sand yeah and all that shit that you
went through that yeah I mean I I don't
like the desert I don't like cold in the
mountains give me the jungle anytime run
my happy camper yeah that'll like
mosquitoes so I'll take the desert of
the balanced but those are the things
you know you know I always say that I
always talk about seeing my guys lined
up to go out my body and their Humvees
are lined up and like if I wasn't going
on Bob who's just like platoon was going
out and I'd stand out just I salute him
like as they were leaves no I just stand
out there and salute as they were
rolling out and what it takes to be the
lead turret gunner in the first Humvee
is more than what it takes to get
through buds like that guy who knows
that there's been you know an ID on the
road he's about to drive by there's been
seven to ten IEDs a day on that road and
he's a lead turret gunner and he's gonna
roll out again and he did it the night
before he did it the week before and he
did it the night before that that's what
the test is and you know plus or minus
viewing
I was on that Boston Whaler - who where
is he he's up at the top right what can
people see him you know any rockets or
anything like that you know where it's
going to go it's now beyond say I want
to stop after the shooting you know me
but uh just a just an example I mean
like as in Subic would be a weird odd
take three week is pretty neat because
the topography there was you go from
triple-canopy jungle down to mangrove to
where the lower Mel was would preserve
their fuel place and stuff well I'd take
my guys up to the about four or five of
them up to the hospital which is up top
we'd go down to the triple-canopy jungle
work away all the way through spend the
night didn't come in and hit the lower
mouth so they had Triple Canopy
in regular jungle and mangos swamp
shadow stuff and they were going to just
to kind of let him know you know yeah
this is what it was like boys yeah
that's all us that's what it's like yeah
so it's like that's why we train hard
and to be prepared for that stuff so
yeah awesome awesome advice echo
speaking of advice sure you have any
advice on how anyone if they want to
maybe support the podcast or support
themselves how they could do that sure
clearly quick question exact quick
question you mentioned the booby traps
like what kind of booby trap what is it
like trip liars all god.you we went
before when we deployed and I don't know
if I say I think it was 70 71 we stopped
in Hawaii and when I was the EOD booby
trap course that they had that they'd
picked up over the years in Vietnam and
set it all up and F we went through that
thing you didn't want to go over just
about because it was unbelievable but
they would do stuff like they'd like to
use to you guys in comm IEDs but they
would be like mortars up in trees and
stuff and they'd use different methods
like a Gunny
yeah they got he got hit with a command
detonated might have been a mortar and
you hit him pretty bad but I bet
sometimes they would take filament down
and put
the fishermen so that you would grab it
you wouldn't feel it on the bottom you
know and a cold set off whatever they
had set up if you usually saw a filament
line that was just kind of sagging and
everything you'd go ahead and cut that
if it was tight you didn't fuck with it
like you say the smart thing you do is
the back way and come in another
direction and the way the our point
Scouts did it they're really good they
would take a thin branch or stick you
know real thin like just like when
you're fishing you can feel the bite on
the line they would take that and they
would hold it kind of in the center and
as we're moving slow they'd move it
anytime that thing dipped they had
reached out and feel it like a lot of
other times if you going down a trail
which isn't a really good idea anyway
but you would step over a log sometimes
they'd put a pressure detonate and stuff
over that log if you stepped on it so
you'd always want to go to the side just
a myriad of things there was a who a lot
of the stuff was command detonated like
we're on those river boats there was
this place called Snoopy snows you know
and we'd have the boats going like this
when they would turn one group of boats
another group of votes would be here and
then they would open up on this group of
boats so they would shoot across but it
wasn't that far to the word the other
boats were and they'd start getting hit
and thinking god damn were being shot at
and you go back and forth or they would
put a b40 rocket then they'd be down
here in a spider hole but they'd have a
like single pulse little and sticking up
and as soon as the boat got right there
they would hit the command thing a
rocket would go off and get the boat
everybody open up here and these guys
would be giggling taking off you know
what I mean this just you know the EOD
guys that we had nowadays in the SEAL
Teams the guys are covered they they go
through workup with up there awesome you
can't you couldn't if someone normal
person was watching they wouldn't be
able to tell who's the idiot who's not
in at least when we're in Ramadi and
that's what most of you guys are like
but my you guys talk about
not want to go over there my EOD guys
they would they would put together
briefs of like the latest the latest ID
that's been out there this is when we're
in Ramadi and you know every couple
every maybe like once certain once every
two weeks they put together more of a
detailed brief of like hey this is what
it does this is this thing and what we
would do is when someone new like let's
say someone was in from out of town or
we had like a visitor that was going to
go on and off with us you know they'd
give that extended brief to teach the
guys well what it actually did was he
would just horrify you note up there but
have nothing with it and yeah we trap
that horse that they had there that I
came like the joke like I you know I've
looked at uld like I see their slide
come up and I the initial slide in the
brief was I could tell it was the big
brief and I look over at the person that
was going like our guest you know maybe
it was like a senior officer someone was
going to come or some Intel person that
was going to go out and op with us and I
look them at the beginning of the EOD
brief and you know they just have a
normal look on their face the by the end
of 22 slides later they look like they
didn't want to go anymore like the VC
would take these of stone things you
have water in itself right and therefore
you're going to a village we didn't do
we didn't usually sweep two villages and
shit then feel about half it up with
gasoline and if they knew the Americans
would come in and take a grenade wrap up
say riggers tape or something that would
just isn't it great as well drop it in
there then as the guys are going through
checking out the reuters everything that
would go off I mean like if we were
going to go into a hooch or something we
would tie a string to the door and then
pull the door open everybody would be
down or if we saw something and then
where the steps were going into it
sometimes if we weren't hitting it quick
you know you check and see what was
under the enemies it was anything but
it's just they were ingenious but ever
really beautiful you know they beat the
French and shit really these guys have
been fighting for a couple of years you
know and anyway go ahead I'm sorry yeah
I know those it it's crazy how they get
smarter and then you guys get smarter
with trying to figure it out then
they're like okay they're trying to
figure out this so they get sort a and
it becomes
the game in the game does help out of
the game now dang you can be mean you
know being in the game okay like that
like that that'll tell you time alpha
bring today apparently she did alpha
brain alpha brain from on it I don't
think there is any other kind of alpha
brain but nonetheless I did take some
and we're going to talk about it not for
too long
so anyway supplements supplementation so
think about the hell's taking krill oil
actually is when I was thinking about
this where would you be if you didn't
take any krill oil or any strong bone
where would you be we don't know behind
we're not outside exactly right so so it
kind of makes me think like okay you
know anyone who's thinking about okay
chocolate would they talk about taking
krill oil all the time how much it helps
and they didn't start taking it you're
behind so my recommendation is take the
krill oil not to mention the alpha brain
not to mention any other supplements
that will help you get to where you want
to be you talk about procrastination
sometimes every once in a while and
that's the biggest thing
by definition it's going to keep you
from doing it you know my kid on the
supplements that's the point there and
if you want 10% off the supplements that
we all know are the best supplements go
to Onix calm slash
Jaco boom there it is support yourself
then you can support others and it's
worth vodcast film there it is also
another way the support pot podcast is
Amazon click-through which means before
you do your amazon shopping click
through the website choco podcast calm
little banner there a good and natural
way to do it is you know when you shop
for the books like the books that you
cover we have a whole page of all the
books all of them click through there
boom it'll take you right to the books
you purchase that's a good way to
support there to support your brain as
well with books and educating yourself
also subscribe to the podcast on iTunes
stitcher Google Play all these other
podcasting providing platforms if you
haven't already that's a good way to do
it leave a review if you can in
mood if you're not a moved in don't do
it or you can still do it if you're not
know whatever you want also YouTube
subscribe to that one
people have been subscribing that's good
it's good because it helps spread the
word seems obvious but when you really
think about it is not as obvious as you
might think because when you get that
alert it's not just the whole podcast as
we always kind of know it's like little
excerpts you know a lot of times or a
little bit more artistic excerpts you'll
be more compelled to share those and we
talked about shareability right when you
get when someone shares it with you
that's one thing you like okay I'll
listen to this it's only two three
minutes long but on the reverse side
when you when you're about to share it
you'll be thinking kind in the other
person's fine they're more into
listening to it because it's shorter
it's subtle but there's a difference so
anyway if you subscribe boom value ha
it'll have that effect on you as well I
know seems magic but it's it's very
explainable anyway point there is
subscribe to YouTube that's a good one
we'll put more videos on there as well
also jockle at the store it's called
Jacko's store Jaakko store calm new rash
guard is out straight up we did it on
the Facebook live I put it live on there
you were there I was there I think it
was your Facebook life I don't think
I've ever done a Facebook live by the
way anyway back to the store this women
stuff on their this t-shirts on there
you have a t-shirts do we gave you
t-shirt right last time give you another
one this stuff - they're pretty dope
there's layers more to the shirts that
then meets the eye where your kid shirt
is out mm or your kid shirts sure adults
and children yeah yeah
also Jocko uniform that's what I'm
calling it the Jocko uniform oh this
shirt victory Emma Mayen fitness shirt
you know the actual original shirt 100%
cotton very soft like a jock Alexis
anyway from I hear all right that's what
I heard anyway a lot of cool stuff I'm
on there if you want to support get
something there's some patches on there
too
velcro patches regulation-size for that
actually we got hats coming up too by
the way
Oh a lot of people they out now not out
there not up I'm saying why are you even
coming I'm saying because when people
make these suggestions and a lot of
people start making okay you know the
more people that make them the more I'm
we we are likely to begin to think about
executing how you make it sound like
such a process long process it's the
process because you can't just have like
two guys saying hey we should get um you
know I don't know something earrings or
something in another guy's yeah that's
clear exactly right story don't ask
local you made my point for me
so Pat's were one of those ones where
there was a lot of people saying we need
that or we should we should have hats
that would be cool
and people were like yeah I think that
too so anyway hats are on the way
somebody's out there I already mentioned
the rash guard I think I think we have a
lot of good stuff on there but we wait
for you to find out is to go to Jacko
store calm and find out for yourself if
you're in the mood get something like
that or get something that's on there
and it will support the budget also good
way to support yourself in your journey
journey are we doing journey or
meandering you've been doing it just so
you know I know but I just I mixed open
about it was it feel not comfortable
yeah I like what other people say and on
myself anyway and you're getting after a
journey waking up early sticking to the
workout sticking to the diet I think
that's the that's the main one yeah I'm
saying maybe but don't say maybe you're
at my house the other day and your power
what were you eating China wings no
there's others that apple pie
well it wasn't apple pie no there was
something nonetheless as far as iets go
I went I went knocked on the chicken
wings
technically the way those were made that
wasn't much of a deviation from the diet
okay anyway the point they're being diet
in Kumar's ding dong what yeah exactly
right and that's the point really even
Jocko gets nuts sometimes it was a
Saturday so that could have been a cheat
day who knows but I'm just saying you
can be on the program and the diet thing
that'll sneak up on you that will sneak
up on you when you're not ready
like if you if you have okay I gotta
wake up to 4:30 you know when the
insurgent is going to come it's going to
come at 4:30 you got to work out at 8:30
or 5 or whatever time you know when the
weakness might come so you can be ready
for it the diet thing you just don't
know so what I'm saying so nonetheless
any moment of weakness this is what you
do you go to iTunes or Amazon music and
get an album with tracks called
psychological warfare all it is is a
bunch of tracks
Jaco telling you why you should not skip
workout you should not hit the snooze
you should not eat the doughnuts no
doughnuts practical logical advice from
Jocko
you know I cannot of people they look
for inspirational you know this is
practical flimsy right inspirational is
very flimsy because it relies on you
feeling like it this has nothing to
restrain this has to do by definition
with you not feeling like it so let
Jocko talk you into making the right
decision boom that's all it is hundred
percent effective
I dare you to skip the workout after
workout and get up whatever the track is
called to the lunch of a month anyway
again psychological warfare iTunes still
number one by the way mm-hmm that's a
check holding holding strong holding
strong for a good reason by the way yeah
also when you're on Amazon you can get
jock a white tea which I'm drinking
right now and the reason I'm drinking it
is because it's delicious by the way
what does it taste like victory
we're the warrior kid book came out
feedbacks been unbelievable getting
photos of kids doing pull-ups studying
doing jujitsu basically getting after in
all realms of getting after it which is
which has been awesome and if you want
your kid to get after it
yeah or other kids around your kid to
get after it and become stronger smarter
and better than get them weighed or your
kid and I just got an email yesterday
for the friend of the family
69 years old does that consider the kid
now a little bit older the kid
kid what guess what he said he learned a
lot from Uncle Jake I did I just
finished it no you finish it a few days
ago I read one or two chapters just
every night routine boom boom with my
four-year-old just finish you understand
it she understands a percentage of it
she's four cudoce especially
understanding package so this is the
plan so she's going to send these really
really basic things and maybe you know
I'm going to just read it over and over
and over so there comes to eat those
kind of thing and then after she gets
older she'll start understanding the
details you know and then the more older
she has someone she understands but her
base we have fought her book more
accurately so boom this guy friend of
the family
69 years old learn from it and then he
won't went buy a copy for all of his
grandchildren each of them individually
so that's good this phone equals freedom
field manual thoughts and actions that's
coming out it's available you can get it
for pre-order right now extreme
ownership of course you can get combat
leadership applied to business and to
life so you can get that book also if
you want to get in the game you can
contact Daschle on front leadership and
management consulting company that we
have that contact is info Daschle on
front comm also the muster is around the
corner
the Austin Texas mustard thirteen and
fourteen of July at the Omni Barton
Creek Resort pragmatic leadership
strategies and tactics that you can
utilize day one no no reason to wait
around
you'll learn them and you'll be sending
emails in a break to your team getting
things fixed there's only three hundred
seats for this because we wanted a
smaller venue and this was the better
venue it's going to sell out so if you
want to come get your tickets now until
the muster if you have any feedback or
questions for us you can find us
actually on the interwebs Twitter
Instagram and on that Facebook
if echo is that echo Charles and I am at
Jocko willing Roger of course has no
social media doesn't care
echo you got anything else I think Roger
Hayden again for coming by
thank you so much yeah I just want to
say though Jellico my husband's going to
teach it so in your studio for about six
months now and all that it he loves it
yeah and he was went to about two and a
half years of this fighting boxing guy
that was really good and but he says
that jiu-jitsu was a plus the
instructors you got our table he'll yeah
he's really likes it he told me to tell
you he really enjoys it and thank you
yeah of course it's it's great to have
our gym victory MMA it's great to have
it and to have it it's just accessible
to people there's no walls around it
open door it cost money of course cuz
you got to pay rent and all that stuff
but not that much not not crazy okay
hundred bucks a month could use a train
any time you want you need to anytime
you want well not 24 hours a day but
6:00 in the morning until 10 o'clock at
night
compared to any other places oh yeah
like literally three times as much
training plus it's not just you JIT so
yeah you got everything there and he
says that's what he likes about it wide
open and he likes ins yeah it's got to
get through boxing Muay Thai wrestling
MMA CrossFit it's got everything in
there and that's why we built it Roger
you got anything else no I'm good then
bumper now now well amen
once again thanks for coming on my
pleasure just awesome to have you on
here and the first time that you were on
I got a million I know you don't do
social media but I got a million people
saying please bring Roger back on please
bring Roger back on and now that you are
on today and you once again you have a
good way of telling little bits of
stories that are awesome and I want to
hear like of one hour story about sea
Wolf's coming in and droppin bombs and
spraying stuff down I'm like how does it
what guy want to learn the
actus what was going on so you're
probably going to have to Anu you're
burned out for today but you probably
have to get on one one more time Evan
and but thanks for coming on again
sharing your story your experience your
wisdom with us and more important of
course thanks for what you did for our
country for the Navy and of course for
the teams
you're absolutely one of the guys that
made the team's what the teams are so
thank you for that
Roger honor to have you on here and for
the rest of the Vietnam veterans and I
hear a lot from Vietnam veterans thanks
to all of you for holding the line and
thank you for every deployment for every
operation every mission every day spend
out on patrol every night span out in
the bush every helicopter assault every
River operation every combat sortie
every case of jungle rot and malaria and
every wound received and every brother
lost thanks to you all for what you did
for us we will never forget so until
next time this is echo and Jocko and
Warrant Officer seal Rodger Hayden out